[Music]
the three or four tillett boards
had stood within the low paling as long
as the inhabitants of the little
triangular square could remember
and if they had ever been vertical it
was a very long time ago
they now overhung the palings each at
its own angle
and resembled nothing so much as a row
of wooden choppers
ever in the act of falling upon some
passerby
yet never cutting off a tenant for the
old house from the stream of his fellows
not that there was ever any great stream
through the square
the stream passed a furlong and more
away beyond the intricacy of tenements
and alleys and byways
that had sprung up since the old house
had been built hemming it in completely
and probably the house itself was only
suffered to stand
pending the falling in of a lease or two
when doubtless a clearance would be made
of the whole neighborhood
it was a bloomy old red brick and built
into its walls where the crowns and
clasped hands and other insignia
of insurance companies long since
defunct
the children of the secluded square had
swung upon the low gate at the end of
the entrance alley
until little more than the solid top bar
of it remained
and the alley itself ran past boarded
basement windows on which tramps had
chalked their cryptic marks
the path was washed and worn uneven by
the spilling of water from the eaves of
the encroaching next house
and cats and dogs had made the approach
their own
the chances of a tenant did not seem
such as to warrant the keeping of the
tillett boards in a state of legibility
and repair
and as a matter of fact they were not so
kept
for six months aleran had passed the old
place
twice a day or offender on his way from
his lodgings to the room
ten minutes walk away he had taken to
work in
and for six months no hatchet-like
notice board had fallen across his path
this might have been due to the fact
that he usually took the other side of
the square but he chanced one morning to
take the side that ran
past the broken gate and the rain worn
entrance alley
and to pause before one of the inclined
boards
the board bore besides the agent's name
the announcement
written apparently about the time of
aleran's own early youth
that the key was to be had at number six
now aleran was already paying for his
separate bedroom and workroom
more than an author who without private
means habitually disregards his public
can afford and he was paying in addition
a small rent for the storage of the
greater part of his grandmother's
furniture
moreover it invariably happened that the
book he wished to read in bed was at his
working quarters half a mile or more
away
while the note or letter he had sudden
need of during the day
was as likely as not to be in the pocket
of another coat hanging behind his
bedroom door
and there were other inconveniences in
having a divided domicile
therefore aleran brought suddenly up by
the hatchet-like notice board
looked first down through some scanty
privet bushes at the boarded basement
windows
then up at the blank and grimy windows
of the first floor
and sew up to the second floor and the
flat stone coping of the leads
he stood for a minute thumbing his lean
and shaven jaw
then with another glance at the board he
walked slowly across the square to
number six
he knocked and waited for two or three
minutes but although the door stood open
received no answer he was knocking again
when a long-nosed man in shirt sleeves
appeared
i was asking a blessing on our food he
said in severe explanation
aleran asked if he might have the key of
the old house
and the long-nosed man withdrew again
aleran waited for another five minutes
on the step
then the man appearing again and
masticating some of the food of which he
had spoken
announced that the key was lost but you
won't want it
he said the entrance door isn't closed
and a push will open any of the others
i'm an agent for it if you're thinking
of taking it
aleron re-crossed the square descended
the two steps at the broken gate
passed along the alley and turned in at
the old wide doorway
to the right immediately within the door
steppes descended to the roomy cellars
and the staircase before him had a
carved rail and was broad and handsome
and filthy aleran ascended it
avoiding contact with the rail and wall
and stopped at the first landing
a door facing him had been boarded up
but he pushed at that on his right hand
and an insecure bolt or staple yielded
he entered the empty first floor he
spent
a quarter of an hour in the place and
then came out again
without mounting higher he descended and
recrossed the square to the house of the
man who had lost the key
can you tell me how much the rent is he
asked
the man mentioned a figure the
comparative lowness of which
seemed accounted for by the character of
the neighborhood and the abominable
state of unrepair of the place
would it be possible to rent a single
floor
the long-nosed man did not know they
might
who are they the man gave aleron the
name of a firm of lawyers and lincoln's
inn
you might mention my name barrett he
added
pressure of work prevented aleran from
going down to lincoln's inn that
afternoon
but he went on the morrow and was
instantly offered the whole house as a
purchase for 50 pounds down
the remainder of the purchase money to
remain on mortgage
it took him half an hour to disabuse the
lawyer's mind
of the idea that he wished anything more
of the place than to rent a single floor
of it
this made certain hums and haws of a
difference and the lawyer was by
no means certain that it lay within his
power to do as all around suggested
but it was finally extracted from him
that provided the notice boards were
allowed to remain
up and that provided it was agreed that
in the event of the whole house letting
the arrangement should terminate
automatically without further notice
something might be done that the old
place should suddenly lead over his head
seemed to alert on the slightest of
risks to take and he promised a decision
within a week
on the morrow he visited the house again
went through it from top to bottom
and then went home to his lodgings to
take a bath
he was immensely taken with that portion
of the house he had already determined
should be his own
scraped clean and repainted and with
that old furniture of aleran's
grandmothers
it ought to be entirely charming he went
to the storage warehouse to refresh his
memory of his half-forgotten belongings
and to take the measurements and thence
he went to a decorator's
he was very busy with his regular work
and could have wished that the notice
board had caught his attention
either a few months earlier or else
later in the year
but the quickest way would be to suspend
work entirely until after his removal
a fortnight later his first floor was
painted throughout in a tender
idea flower white the paint was dry
and aleran was in the middle of his
installation
he was animated delighted and he rubbed
his hands as he polished and made
disposals of his grandmother's effects
the tall lattice-parted china cupboard
with its derby and mason and spode
the large folding sheraton table the
long low bookshelves
he had had two of them copied the chairs
the sheffield candlesticks
the riveted rose bowls these things he
said against his newly painted either
white walls
walls of wood paneled in the happiest
proportions
and molded and coffered to the low
seeded window recesses
in a mood of gaity and rest that the
builders of rooms no longer know
the ceilings were lofty and faintly
painted with an old pattern of stars
even the tapering moldings of his iron
fireplace were as delicately designed as
jewelry
and oliron walked about rubbing his
hands frequently stopping for the mere
pleasure of the glimpses from white room
to white room
charming charming he said to himself
i wonder what elsie bengo will think of
this
he bought a bolt and a yale lock for his
door and shut off his quarters from the
rest of the house
if he now wanted to read in bed his book
could be had for stepping into the next
room
all the time he thought how exceedingly
lucky he was to get the place
he put up a hat rack in the little
square hall and hung up his hats and
caps and coats
and passers through the small triangular
square late at night
looking up over the little seried row of
wooden tillett hatchets
could see the light within aileron's red
blinds or else the sudden darkening of
one blind and the illumination of
another
as aleron candlestick in hand passed
from room to room
making final settings of his furniture
or preparing to resume the work that his
removal had interrupted
as far as the chief business of his life
his writing
was concerned paul aleran treated the
world a good deal better than he was
treated by it
but he seldom took the trouble to strike
a balance or to compute how far at 44
years of age
he was behind his points on the handicap
to have done so wouldn't have altered
matters and it might have depressed
aleran
he had chosen his path and was committed
to it beyond possibility of withdrawal
perhaps he had chosen it in the days
when he had been easily swayed by
something a little disinterested
a little generous a little noble and had
he ever thought of questioning himself
he would still have held to it that a
life without nobility
and generosity and disinterestedness was
no life for him
only quite recently and rarely had he
even vaguely suspected that there was
more in it than this
but it was no good anticipating the day
when he supposed
he would reach that maximum point of his
powers beyond which he must
inevitably decline and be left face to
face with the question whether it would
not have profited him better
to have ruled his life by less exigent
ideals
in the meantime his removal into the old
house with the insurance marks built
into its brick
merely interrupted romilly bishop at the
15th chapter
as this tall man with the lean ascetic
face moved about
his new abode arranging changing
altering
hardly yet into his working stride again
he gave the impression of almost
spinster-like precision and nicety
for 20 years past in a score of lodgings
garretts
fiats and rooms furnished and
unfurnished he had been accustomed to do
many things for himself
and he had discovered that it saves time
and temper to be
methodical he had arranged with the wife
of the long-nosed barrett a stout welsh
woman with a falsetto voice
the marion shire accent of which long
residents in london had not perceptibly
modified
to come across the square each morning
to prepare his breakfast
and also to turn the place out on
saturday mornings
and for the rest he even welcomed a
little housework as a relaxation from
the strain of writing
his kitchen together with the adjoining
strip of an apartment
into which a modern bath had been fitted
overlooked the alley at the side of the
house
and at one end of it was a large closet
with a door and a square sliding hatch
in the upper part of the door
this had been a powder closet and
through the hatch the elaborately
dressed head had been thrust
to receive the click and puff of the
powder pistol
aleran puzzled a little over this closet
then as its use occurred to him
he smiled faintly a little moved he knew
not by what
he would have to put it to a very
different purpose from its original one
it would probably have to serve as his
larder
it was in this closet that he made a
discovery
the back of it was shelved and rummaging
on an upper shelf that ran deeply
into the wall aleran found a couple of
mushroom-shaped old wooden wig stands
he did not know how they had come to be
there doubtless the painters had turned
them up somewhere or other
and had put them there but his five
rooms as a whole
were short of cupboard and closet room
and it was only by the exercise of some
ingenuity that he was able to find
places for the bestowal of his household
linen
his boxes and is seldom used but not to
be destroyed
accumulation of papers it was in the
early spring that aleran entered on his
tenancy
and he was anxious to have romilly ready
for publication
in the coming autumn nevertheless he did
not intend to force its production
should it demand longer in the doing so
much the worse
he realized its importance its crucial
importance
in his artistic development and it must
have its own length and time
in the work room he had recently left he
had been making excellent progress
romilly had begun as the saying is to
speak and act of herself
and he did not doubt she would continue
to do so the moment the distraction of
his removal was over
this distraction was almost over he told
himself
it was time he pulled himself together
again and on a march morning
he went out returned again with two
great bunches of yellow daffodils
placed one bunch on his mantelpiece
between the sheffield sticks
and the other on the table before him
and took out the half-completed
manuscript of romely bishop
but before beginning work he went to a
small rosewood cabinet
and took from a drawer his checkbook and
passbook
he tatted them up and his monk-like face
grew thoughtful
his installation had cost him more than
he had intended it should
and his balance was rather less than 50
pounds
with no immediate prospect of more
hmm i'd forgotten rugs and chintz
curtains and so forth melted up so
said aleran but it would have been a
pity to spoil the place for the want of
ten pounds or so
well romilly simply must be out for the
autumn that's
all so here goes he drew his papers
towards him
but he worked badly or rather he did not
work at all
the square outside had its own noises
frequent and new
and aleron could only hope that he would
speedily become accustomed to these
first came hawkers with their carts and
cries
at midday the children returning from
school trooped into the square
and swung on aileron's gate and when the
children had departed again for
afternoon school
an itinerant musician with a mandolin
posted himself beneath aleran's window
and began to strum
this was a not unpleasant distraction
and aleran
pushing up his window threw the man a
penny then he returned to his table
again
but it was no good he came to himself at
long intervals
to find that he had been looking about
his room and wondering how it had
formerly been furnished
whether a seti in buttercup or petunia
satin had stood under the farther window
whether from the center molding of the
light lofty ceiling had depended a
glimmering crystal chandelier
or where the timbre frame or the pk
table had stood
no it was no good he had far better be
frankly doing nothing
than getting fruitlessly tired and he
decided that he would take a walk
but chancing to sit down for a moment
dozed in his chair
instead this won't do he yawned when he
awoke at half past four in the afternoon
i must do better than this tomorrow
and he felt so deliciously lazy that for
some minutes he even contemplated the
breach of an appointment he had for the
evening
the next morning he sat down to work
without even permitting himself to
answer one of his three letters
two of them tradesman's accounts the
third a note from miss bengo
forwarded from his old address it was a
jolly day of white and blue
with a gay noisy wind and a subtle turn
in the color of growing things
and over and over again once or twice a
minute
his room became suddenly light and then
subdued again
as the shining white clouds robed
northeastwards over the square
the soft fitful illumination was
reflected in the polished surface of the
table
and even in the footworn old floor and
the morning noises had begun again
aleran made a pattern of dots on the
paper before him
and then broke off to move the jar of
daffodils exactly opposite the center of
a creamy panel
then he wrote a sentence that ran
continuously for a couple of lines
after which it broke off into notes and
jottings
for a time he succeeded in persuading
himself that in making these memoranda
he was really working then he rose and
began to pace his room
as he did so he was struck by an idea
it was that the place might possibly be
a little better for more positive color
it was perhaps a thought too pale mild
and sweet as a kind old face
but a little devitalized even won
yes decidedly it would bear a robuster
note
more and richer flowers and possibly
some warm and gay stuff for cushions for
the window seats
of course i really can't afford it he
muttered as he went for a two foot and
began to measure the width of the window
recesses
in stooping to measure a recess his
attitude suddenly changed to one of
interest and attention
presently he rose again rubbing his
hands with gentle glee
oh ho he said these look to me very much
like window boxes nailed up
we must look into this yes those are
boxes or i'm
oh this is an adventure on that wall of
his sitting room there were two windows
the third was in another corner and
beyond the open bedroom door
on the same wall was another the seats
of all had been
painted repainted and painted again and
aleran's investigating finger had barely
detected the old nail heads beneath the
paint
under the ledge over which he stooped an
old keyhole had also been puttied up
aleron took out his pen knife he worked
carefully for five minutes
and then went into the kitchen for a
hammer and chisel
driving the chisel cautiously under the
seat he started the whole lid slightly
again using the pen knife he cut along
the hinged edge
and outward along the ends and then he
fetched a wedge in a wooden mallet
now for our little mystery he said
the sound of the mallet on the wedge
seemed in that sweet and pale apartment
somehow a little brutal naive and
shocking
the paneling rang and rattled and
vibrated to the blows like a sounding
board
the whole house seemed to echo from the
roomy celeridge to the garrets above
a flock of echoes seemed to awake and
the sound got a little on aleron's
nerves
all at once he paused fetched a duster
and muffled the mallet
when the edge was sufficiently raised he
put his fingers under it and lifted
the paint flaked and starred a little
the rusty old nails squeaked and grunted
and the lid came up laying open the box
beneath
aleran looked into it save for a couple
of inches of scarf and mold and old
cobwebs
it was empty no treasure there
said aleran a little amused that he
should have fancied there might have
been
romely will still have to be out by
autumn let's have a look at the
others he turned to the second window
the raising of the two remaining seats
occupied him until well into the
afternoon
that of the bedroom like the first was
empty but from the second seat of his
sitting room
he drew out something yielding and
folded and furred over an
inch thick with dust he carried the
object into the kitchen
and having swept it over a bucket took a
duster to it
it was some sort of a large bag of an
ancient freeze-like material
and when unfolded it occupied the
greater part of the small kitchen floor
in shape it was an irregular a very
irregular triangle
and it had a couple of wide flaps with
the remains of straps and buckles
the patch that had been uppermost in the
folding was of a faded yellowish brown
but the rest of it was shades of crimson
that varied according to the exposure of
the parts of it
now whatever can that have been aleron
mused as he stood surveying it
i give it up whatever it is it settled
my work for today i'm afraid
he folded the object up carelessly and
thrust it into a corner of the kitchen
then taking pans and brushes and an old
knife
he returned to the sitting room and
began to scrape and to wash
and to line with paper his newly
discovered receptacles
when he had finished he put his spare
boots and books and papers into them
and he closed the lids again amused with
his little adventure
but also a little anxious for the hour
to come when he should settle fairly
down to his work again
it peaked all around a little that his
friend miss bengo
should dismiss with a glance the place
he himself had found so singularly
winning
indeed she scarcely lifted her eyes to
it but then she had always been more or
less like that
a little indifferent to the graces of
life careless of appearances
and perhaps a shade more herself when
she ate biscuits from a paper bag
than when she dined with greater
observance of the conveniences
she was an unattached journalist of 34
large showy fair as butter pink as a dog
rose
reminding one of a florist-picked
specimen bloom and given to sudden and
ample movements and moist and explosive
utterances
she pulled a better living out of the
pool as she expressed it
than aleron did and by cunningly
disguised puffs of drapers and
haberdashers
she pulled also the greater part of her
very varied wardrobe
she left small whirlwinds of air behind
her when she moved
in which her veils and scarves fluttered
and spun
aleron heard the flurry of her skirts on
his staircase and her single loud knock
in his door
when he had been a month in his new
abode her garments brought in the outer
air and she flung a bundle of ladies
journals down on a chair
don't knock off for me she said across a
mouthful of large-headed hat pins as she
removed her hat and veil
i didn't know whether you were straight
yet so i bought some sandwiches for
lunch
you've got coffee i suppose no don't get
up i'll find the kitchen
oh that's all right i'll clear these
things away to tell the truth i'm rather
glad to be interrupted
said alerron he gathered his work
together and put it away
she was already in the kitchen he heard
the running of water into the kettle
he joined her and ten minutes later
followed her back to the sitting room
with the coffee and sandwiches on a tray
they sat down with a tray on a small
table between them
well what do you think of the new place
aleran asked is she poured out coffee
anybody think you were going to get
married paul he laughed
oh no but it's an improvement on some of
them isn't it
is it i suppose it is i don't know i
liked the last place
in spite of the black ceiling and no
water tap how's romilly
aleron thumbed his chin hm i'm rather
ashamed to tell you
the fact is i have not got on very well
with it but it'll be all right on the
night as you used to say
stuck rather stuck
got any of it you care to read to me
aleran had long been in the habit of
reading portions of his work to miss
bengo occasionally
her comments were always quick and
practical sometimes directly useful
sometimes indirectly suggestive she in
return for his confidence
always kept all mention of her own work
schedulously from him
his she said was real work hers merely
filled space
not always even grammatically i'm afraid
there isn't
aleron replied still meditatively dry
shaving his chin
then he added with a little burst of
candor the fact is elsie i've not
written
not actually written very much more of
it any more of it in fact
but of course that doesn't mean i
haven't progressed i've progressed in
one sense rather alarmingly
i'm now thinking of reconstructing the
whole thing
miss bengo gave a gasp reconstructing
making romilly herself a different type
of woman
somehow i've begun to feel that i'm not
getting the most out of her
as she stands i've certainly lost
interest in her to some extent
but but miss bengo protested
you had her so real so living paul
aleron smiled faintly he had been quite
prepared for miss bengo's disapproval
he wasn't surprised that she liked
romilly as she at present existed
she would whether she realized it or not
there was much of herself in his
fictitious creation
naturally romilly would seem real and
living to her
but are you really serious paul miss
bengo asked presently with a round-eyed
stare
quite serious you're really going to
scrap
those 15 chapters i didn't exactly say
that
that fine rich love scene i should only
do it reluctantly and for the sake of
something i thought better
and that beautiful beautiful description
of ramely on the shore
it wouldn't necessarily be wasted he
said a little uneasily
but miss bengo made a large and windy
gesture and then let him have it
really you are too trying she broke out
i do wish sometimes you remember you're
human
and live in a world you know i'd be the
last to wish you to lower your standard
one inch
but it wouldn't be lowering it to bring
it within human comprehension
you're sometimes altogether too godlike
why it would be a wicked criminal waste
of your powers to destroy those 15
chapters
look at it reasonably now you've been
working for nearly 20 years
you've now got what you've been working
for almost within your grasp
your affairs are at a most critical
stage oh don't tell me i know you're
about at the end of your money
and here you are deliberately proposing
to withdraw a thing that will probably
make your name
and to substitute for it something that
10 to 1 nobody on earth will ever want
to read
and small blame to them really you try
my patience
aleran had shaken his head slowly as she
had talked
it was an old story between them the
noisy able practical journalist was an
admirable friend
up to a certain point beyond that
well each of us knows that point beyond
which we stand alone
elsie bengo sometimes said that had she
had one tenth part of allaron's genius
there were a few things she could not
have done thus making that genius a
quantitatively divisible thing
a sort of ingredient to be added to or
subtracted from
in the admixture of his work that it was
a qualitative thing
essential indivisible informing pastor
comprehension
their spirits parted company at that
point aleran knew it
she did not appear to know it yes yes
yes
he said a little wearily by and by
practically you're quite right
entirely right and i haven't a word to
say if i could only turn romilly over to
you you'd make an enormous success of
her
but that can't be and i for my part am
seriously doubting whether she's worth
my while
you know what that means what does it
mean
she demanded bluntly well he said
smiling wandly
what does it mean when you're convinced
a thing isn't worth doing
you simply don't do it ms bengo's eyes
swept the ceiling for assistance against
this impossible man
what utter rubbish she broke out at last
why when i saw you last you were simply
oozing romely you were turning her off
at the rate of four chapters a week
if you hadn't moved you'd have had her
three parts done by now
what on earth possess you to move right
in the middle of your most important
work
aleran tried to put her off with a
recital of inconveniences
but she wouldn't have it perhaps in her
heart she partly suspected the reason
he was simply mortally weary of the
narrow circumstances
of his life he had had 20 years of it
20 years of garretts and roof chambers
and dingy flats
and shabby lodgings and he was tired of
dinginess and shabbiness
the reward was as far off as ever or if
it was not he no longer cared once he
would have cared to put out his hand and
take it
it is all very well to tell a man who is
at the point of exhaustion
that only another effort is required of
him if he cannot make it he is as far
off as
ever anyway aleran summed up
i'm happier here than i've been for a
long time that's some sort of a
justification
and doing no work said miss bengo
pointedly
at that a trifling petulance that had
been gathering at aleron came to a head
and why should i do nothing but work he
demanded how much happier am i for it
i don't say i don't love my work when
it's done but i hate doing it
sometimes it's an intolerable burden
that i simply long to be rid of
once in many weeks it has a moment one
moment of glow and thrill for me
i remember the days when it was all glow
and thrill and now i'm 44
and it's becoming drudgery nobody wants
it
i'm ceasing to want it myself and if any
ordinary sensible man were to ask me
whether i didn't think i was a fool to
go on
i think i should agree that i was ms
bengo's comely pink face was serious
but you knew all that many many years
ago paul
and still you chose it she said in a low
voice
well and how should i have known he
demanded i didn't know
i was told so my heart if you like
told me so and i thought i knew youth
always thinks it knows
then one day it discovers that it is
nearly fifty
forty-four paul forty-four then and it
finds that the glamour isn't in front
but behind
yes i knew and chose if that's knowing
and choosing
but it's a costly choice we're called on
to make when we're young
miss bengo's eyes were on the floor
without moving them she said
you're not regretting it paul am i not
he took her up upon my word i've lately
thought i am
what do i get in return for it all you
know what you get
she replied he might have known from her
tone what else he could have had for the
holding up of a finger
herself she knew but could not tell him
that he could have done no better thing
for himself had he
any time these 10 years asked her to
marry him
she would have replied quietly very well
when he had never thought of it
yours is the real work she continued
quietly
without you we jackals couldn't exist
you and a few like you hold everything
upon your shoulders for a minute there
was a silence
then it occurred to aleran that this was
common vulgar grumbling
it was not his habit suddenly he rose
and began to stack cups and plates on
the tray
sorry you catch me like this elsie he
said with a little laugh
no i'll take them out then we'll go for
a walk if you like
he carried out the tray and then began
to show miss bengo around his flat
she made few comments in the kitchen she
asked what an old faded square of
reddish freeze was
that miss barrett used as a cushion for
her wooden chair
that i should be glad if you could tell
me what it is alaron replied as he
unfolded the bag
and related the story of its finding in
the window seat
i think i know what it is said miss
bengo it's been used to wrap up a harp
before putting it in its case by jove
that's probably just what it was
said aleran i couldn't make neither head
nor tail of it
they finished the tour of the flat and
returned to the sitting room
and who lives in the rest of the house
miss bengo asked
i dare say a [ __ ] sleeps in the cellar
occasionally nobody else hm
well i'll tell you what i think of it if
you like
i should like you'll never work here
oh said aleran quickly why not
you'll never finish romilly here why i
don't know
but you won't i know it you'll have to
leave before you get on with that book
he mused a moment and then said isn't
that a little
prejudiced elsie perfectly ridiculous
as an argument it hasn't a leg to stand
on but there it is
she replied her mouth once more full of
the large-headed hat pins
i can only hope you're entirely wrong he
said for i shall be in a serious mess if
romilly isn't out in the autumn
as alaron sat by his fire that evening
pondering miss bengo's prognostication
that difficulties awaited him in his
work he came to the conclusion that it
would have been
far better and she kept her beliefs to
herself
no man does a thing better for having
his confidence damped at the outset
and to speak of difficulties is in a
sense to make them
speech itself becomes a deterrent act to
which other discouragements accrete
until the very event of which warning is
given is as likely as not to come to
pass
he heartily confounded her an influence
hostile to the completion of ramalei had
been born
and in some illogical dogmatic way women
seemed to have
she had attached this antagonistic
influence to his new abode
was ever anything so absurd you'll never
finish romely here
why not was this her idea of the luxury
that saps the springs of action
and brings a man down to indolence and
dropping out of the race
the place was well enough it was
entirely charming for that matter
but it was not so demoralizing as all
that
no elsie had missed the mark that time
he moved his chair to look round the
room that smiled positively smiled in
the fire light
he too smiled as if pity was to be
entertained for a maligned apartment
even that slight lack of robust color he
had remarked was not noticeable in the
soft glow
the drawn chintz curtains they had a
flowered and trellised pattern with
baskets and oaten pipes
fell in long quiet folds to the window
seats
the rows of bindings and old bookcases
took the light richly
the last trace of sallowness had gone
with the daylight
and if the truth must be told it had
been elsie herself who had seemed a
little out of the picture
that reflection struck him a little and
presently he returned to it
yes the room had quite accidentally done
miss bengo a disservice that afternoon
it had in some subtle but unmistakable
way
placed her marked a contrast of
qualities
assuming for the sake of argument the
slightly ridiculous proposition
that the room in which aleran sat was
characterized by a certain sparsity and
lack of vigor
so much the worse for miss bengo she
certainly aired on the side of
redundancy and general mutchness
and if one must contrast abstract
qualities
alert inclined to the austere in taste
yes here aleron had made a distinct
discovery
he wondered he had not made it before he
pictured miss bengo again
as she had appeared that afternoon large
showy moistly pink with that quality of
the prize bloom exuding as it were
from her and instantly she suffered in
his thought
he even recognized now that he had
noticed something odd at the time
and that unconsciously his attitude even
while she had been there
had been one of criticism the mechanism
of her was a little obvious
her melting humidity was the result of
analyzable processes
and behind her there seemed to lurk some
dim shape emblematic of mortality
he had never during the 10 years of
their intimacy dreamed for a moment of
asking her to marry him
nonetheless he now felt for the first
time a thankfulness that he had not done
so
then suddenly and swiftly his face
flamed that he should be thinking thus
of his friend
what elsie bengo with whom he had spent
weeks and weeks of afternoons
she the good chum on whose help he would
have counted had all the rest of the
world failed him
she whose loyalty to him would not he
knew swerve as long as there was breath
in her elsie to be even in thought
dissected thus
he was an ingrate and a cad had she been
there in that moment he would have
abased himself before her
for 10 minutes and more he sat still
gazing into the fire
with that humiliating red fading slowly
from his cheeks
all was still within and without save
for a tiny musical tinkling that came
from his kitchen
the dripping of water from an
imperfectly turned off tap
into the vessel beneath it mechanically
he began to beat with his finger
to the faintly heard falling of the
drops the tiny regular movement seemed
to hasten that shameful withdrawal from
his face
he grew cool once more and when he
resumed his meditation he was all
unconscious that he took it up again
at the same point it was not only her
florid superfluity of build that he had
approached in the attitude of criticism
he was conscious also of the wide
differences between her mind and his own
he felt no thankfulness that up to a
certain point their natures had ever run
companionably side by side he was now
full of questions beyond that point
their intellects diverged there was no
denying it
and looking back he was inclined to
doubt whether there had been any real
coincidence
true he had read his writings to her and
she had appeared to speak
comprehendingly and to the point but
what can a man do
who having assumed that another sees as
he does
is suddenly brought up sharp by
something that falsifies and discredits
all that has gone before
he doubted all now it did for a moment
occur to him that the man who demands of
a friend more than can be given to him
is in danger of losing that friend but
he put the thought aside
again he ceased to think and again moved
his finger to the distant dripping of
the tap
and now he resumed by and by if these
things were true of elsie bengo
they were also true of the creation of
which she was the prototype
romilly bishop and since he could say of
romilly
what for very shame he could not say of
elsie he gave his thoughts
rain he did so in that smiling
fire-lighted room
to the accompaniment of the faintly
heard tab
there was no longer any doubt about it
he hated the central character of his
novel
even as he had described her physically
she overpowered the senses
she was coarse-fibered over colored rank
it became true the moment he formulated
his thought
gulliver had described the
brobdingnagian maids of honor thus
and mentally and spiritually she
corresponded was
unsensitive limited common
the model he closed his eyes for a
moment the model stuck out through 15
vulgar and blatant chapters to such a
pitch that without seeing the reason he
had been unable to begin the 16th
he marveled that it only just dawned
upon him
and this was to have been his beatrice
his vision
as elsie she was to have gone into the
furnace of his art
and she was to have come out the woman
all men desire
her thoughts were to have been culled
from his own finest
her form from his dearest dreams and her
setting wherever he could find one
fit for her worth he had brooded long
before making the attempt
then one day he had felt her stir within
him as a mother feels a quickening
and he had begun to write and so he had
added chapter to chapter
and those 15 sodden chapters were what
he had produced
again he sat softly moving his finger
then he bestowed himself she must go
all 15 chapters of her that was settled
for what was to take her place his mind
was a blank
but one thing at a time a man is not
excused from taking the wrong course
because the right one is not immediately
revealed to him
better would come if it was to come in
the meantime
he rose fetched the 15 chapters and read
them over
before he should drop them into the fire
but instead of putting them into the
fire he let them fall from his hand
he became conscious of the dripping of
the tap again
it had a tinkling gamut of four or five
notes
on which it rang irregular changes and
it was foolishly sweet and dulcimer-like
in his mind aleran could see the
gathering of each drop
its little tremble on the lip of the tap
and the tiny percussion of its fall
plink plunk minimized almost to
inaudibility
following the lowest note there seemed
to be a brief phrase
irregularly repeated and presently
aleran found himself waiting for the
recurrence of this phrase
it was quite pretty but it did not
conduce to wakefulness
and aleron dozed over his fire
when he awoke again the fire had burned
low and the flames of the candles were
licking the rims of the sheffield sticks
sluggishly he rose yawned went his
nightly round of door locks and window
fastenings
and passed into his bedroom soon he
slept soundly
but a curious little sequel followed on
the morrow
mrs barrett usually tapped not at his
door but at the wooden wall
beyond which lay aleran's bed and then
aleron rose
put on his dressing gown and admitted
her he was not conscious that as he did
so
that morning he hummed an air but mrs
barrett lingered with her hand on the
doorknob
and her face a little averted and
smiling
dear me her soft falsetto rose
but that will be a very old tune mr
aleran i will not have heard it this 40
years
what tune aleran asked the tune indeed
that she was humming sir
aleron had his thumb in the flap of a
letter it remained there
i was humming sing it mrs barrett
mrs barrett prut pretted i have no voice
for singing mr alderon
it was ann pugh was the singer of our
family but the tune will be very old
and it is called the beckoning fair one
try to sing it said aleran his thumb
still in the envelope
and mrs barrett with much dimpling and
confusion
hummed the air they do say it was sung
to a harp
mr aleran and it will be very old she
concluded
and i was singing that indeed you was
i would not be likely to tell you lies
with a very well let me have breakfast
aleran opened his letter but the
trifling circumstance struck him as more
odd than he would have admitted to
himself
the phrase he had hummed had been that
which he had associated with the falling
from the tap
on the evening before
even more curious than that the
commonplace dripping of an ordinary
water tab
should have tallied so closely with an
actually existing air
was another result it had namely that it
awakened or
seemed to awaken in aleron an abnormal
sensitiveness to other noises of the old
house
it has been remarked that silence
obtains its fullest and most impressive
quality
when it is broken by some minute sound
and truth to tell
the place was never still perhaps the
mildness of the spring
air operated on its torpid old timbers
perhaps aleran's fires caused it to
stretch its old anatomy
and certainly a whole world of insect
life bored and burrowed in its box and
joists
at any rate aleran had only to sit quiet
in his chair and to wait for a minute or
two
in order to become aware of such a
change in the auditory scale
as comes upon a man who conceiving the
midsummer woods to be motionless and
still
all at once finds his ears sharpened to
the crepitation of a myriad insects
and he smiled to think of man's
arbitrary distinction between that which
has life
and that which has not here quite apart
from such recognizable sounds as the
scampering of mice
the falling of plaster behind his
paneling and the popping of purses or
coffins from his fire
was a whole house talking to him had he
but known its language
beams settled with a tired sigh into
their old mortises
creatures ticked in the walls joints
cracked
boards complained with no palpable
stirring of the air
window sashes changed their positions
with a soft knock in their frames
and whether the place had life in this
sense or not it had at all events a
winsome personality
it needed but an hour of musing for
aleron to conceive the idea
that as his own body stood in friendly
relation to his soul
so by an extension and an attenuation
his habitation might fantastically be
supposed to stand in some relation to
himself
he even amused himself with a
far-fetched fancy that he might so
identify himself with the place that
some future tenant
taking possession might regard it as in
a sense
haunted it would be rather a joke if he
a perfectly harmless author
with nothing on his mind worse than a
novel he had discovered he must begin
again
should turn out to be laying the
foundation of a future ghost
in proportion however as he felt this
growing attachment to the fabric of his
abode
elsie bengo from being merely
unattracted
began to show a dislike of the place
that was more and more marked
and she did not scruple to speak of her
aversion
it doesn't belong to today at all and
for you especially it's bad
she said with decision you're only too
ready to let go your hold on actual
things and to slip into apathy
you ought to be in a place with concrete
floors and a patent gas meter and a
tradesman's lift
and it would do you all the good in the
world if you had a job that made you
scramble and rub elbows with your fellow
men
now if i could get you a job for say two
or three days a week
one that would allow you heaps of time
for your proper work
would you take it somehow aleran
resented a little
being diagnosed like this he thanked
miss bengo but without a smile
thank you but i don't think so after all
each of us has his own life to live
he could not refrain from adding his own
life to live
how long is it since you were out paul
about two hours
i don't mean to buy stamps or to post a
letter how long is it since you had
anything like a stretch
oh some little time perhaps i don't know
since i was here last i haven't been out
much
and has romilly progressed much better
for your being cooped up
i think she has i'm laying the
foundations of her
i shall begin the actual writing
presently
it seemed as if miss bengo had forgotten
their tussle about the first romilly
she frowned turned half away and then
quickly turned again
ah so you've still got that ridiculous
idea in your head
if you mean said alerron slowly that
i've discarded the old
romilly and i'm at work on a new one
you're right i have still got that idea
in my head
something uncordial in his tone struck
her but she was a fighter
his own absurd sensitiveness hardened
her she gave a pasha of impatience
where's the old one she demanded
abruptly
why asked dalaran i want to see it
i want to show some of it to you i want
if you're not wool gathering entirely
to bring you back to your senses this
time it was he who turned his back
but when he turned round again he spoke
more gently
it's no good elsie i'm responsible for
the way i go
and you must allow me to go it even if
it should seem wrong to you
believe me i am giving thought to it the
manuscript
i was on the point of burning it but i
didn't it's in that window seat if you
must see it
miss bengo crossed quickly to the window
seat and lifted the lid
suddenly she gave a little exclamation
and put the back of her hand to her
mouth
she spoke over her shoulder you ought to
knock those nails in paul
she said he strode to her side what
what is it what's the matter he asked i
did knock them in
or rather pulled them out you left
enough to scratch with
she replied showing her hand from the
upper wrist to the knuckle of the little
finger
a welling red wound showed good gracious
ulron ejaculated here come to the
bathroom and bathe it quickly
he hurried her to the bathroom turned on
warm water and bathed and cleansed the
bad gash
then still holding the hand he turned
cold water on it
uttering broken phrases of astonishment
and concern
good lord how did that happen as far as
i knew i'd
is this water too cold does that hurt i
can't imagine how on earth
there that'll do no one moment longer
i can bear it she murmured her eyes
closed
presently he led her back to the sitting
room and bound the hand in one of his
handkerchiefs
but his face did not lose its expression
of perplexity
he had spent half a day in opening and
making serviceable the three window
boxes
and he could not conceive how he had
come to leave an inch and a half of
rusty nails standing in the wood
he himself had opened the lids of each
of them a dozen times
and had not noticed any nail but there
it was
it shall come out now at all events he
muttered as he went for a pair of
pinchers
and he made no mistake about it that
time
elsie bengo had sunk into a chair and
her face was rather white
but in her hand was the manuscript of
ramalee she had not finished with
romilly yet
presently she returned to the charge oh
paul it will be the greatest mistake you
ever
ever made if you do not publish this she
said
he hung his head genuinely distressed he
couldn't get that incident of the nail
out of his head
and romely occupied a second place in
his thoughts for the moment
but still she insisted and when
presently he spoke it was almost as if
he asked her pardon for something
what can i say elsie i can only hope
that when you see the new version you'll
see how right i am
and if in spite of all you don't like
her well
he made a hopeless gesture don't you see
that i must be guided by my own lights
she was silent come elsie he said gently
we've got along well so far don't let us
split on this
the last words had hardly passed his
lips before he regretted them
she had been nursing her injured hand
with her eyes once more closed
but her lips and lids quivered
simultaneously
her voice shook as she spoke i can't
help saying it paul
but you were so greatly changed huh
chelsea he murmured soothingly
you've had a shock rest for a while how
could i change
i don't know but you are you've not been
yourself ever since you came here
i wish you'd never seen the place it
stopped your work it's making you into a
person i hardly know
and it's made me horribly anxious about
you oh how my hand is beginning to throb
poor child he murmured will you let me
take you to a doctor and have it
properly dressed
no i shall be all right presently i'll
keep it raised
she put her elbow on the back of her
chair and the bandaged hand rested
lightly on his shoulder
at that touch an entirely new anxiety
stirred suddenly within him
hundreds of times previously on their
jaunts and excursions
she had slipped her hand within his arm
as she might have slipped it into the
arm of a brother
and he had accepted the little
affectionate gesture as a brother might
have accepted it
but now for the first time there rushed
into his mind a hundred
startling questions her eyes were still
closed
and her head had fallen pathetically
back and there was a lost and ineffable
smile on her parted lips
the truth broke in upon him good god
and he had never divined it and stranger
than all was that
now that he did see that she was lost in
love of him
there came to him not sorrow and
humility in a basement
but something else that he struggled in
vain against
something entirely strange and new that
had he analyzed
it he would have found to be petulance
and irritation and resentment
and ungentleness the sudden selfish
prompting mastered him before he was
aware
he all but gave it words what was she
doing there at all
why was she not getting on with her own
work why was she here interfering with
his
who had given her this guardianship over
him that lately she had put forward so
assertively
changed it was she not himself who had
changed
but by the time she had opened her eyes
again he had overcome his resentment
sufficiently to speak
gently albeit with reserve i wish you
would let me take you to a doctor
she rose no thank you paul she said
i'll go now if i need a dressing i'll
get one
take the other hand please goodbye
he did not attempt to detain her he
walked with her to the foot of the
stairs
halfway along the narrow alley she
turned
it would be a long way to come if you
happen not to be in
she said i'll send you a postcard the
next time
at the gate she turned again leave here
paul
she said with a mournful look
everything's wrong with this house
then she was gone aleran returned to his
room
he crossed straight to the window box he
opened the lid and stood long looking at
it
then he closed it again and turned away
that's rather frightening he muttered
it's simply not possible that i should
not have removed that nail
aleran knew very well what elsie had
meant when she had said that her next
visit would be preceded by a postcard
she too had realized that at last at
last he knew
knew and didn't want her it gave him a
miserable pitiful pang therefore when
she came again within a week
knocking at the door unannounced she
spoke from the landing
she did not intend to stay she said and
he had to press her before she would so
much as enter
her excuse for calling was that she had
heard of an inquiry
for short stories that he might be wise
to follow up
he thanked her then her business over
she seemed anxious to get away again
aleran did not seek to detain her
even though he saw through the pretext
of the stories and he accompanied her
down the stairs
but elsie bengo had no luck whatever in
that house
a second accident befell her halfway
down the staircase there was the sharp
sound of splintering wood
and she checked a loud cry aleran knew
the woodwork to be old
but he himself had ascended and
descended frequently enough without
mishap
elsie had put her foot through one of
the stairs
he sprang to her side an alarm oh i say
my poor girl she laughed hysterically
it's my weight i know i'm getting fat
keep still
let me clear these splinters away he
muttered between his teeth
she continued to laugh and sob that it
was her weight that she was getting fat
he thrust downwards at the broken boards
the extrication was no easy matter and
her torn boot showed him how badly the
foot and ankle within it must be abraded
good god good god he muttered over and
over again
i shall be too heavy for anything soon
she sobbed and laughed
but she refused to reassend and to
examine her hurt
no let me go quickly let me go quickly
she repeated
but it's a frightful gash no not so bad
let me get away quickly i'm i'm not
wanted
at her words that she was not wanted his
head dropped as if she had given him a
buffet
elsie he choked brokenly and shocked
but she too made a quick gesture as if
she put something violently aside
oh paul not that not you of course i do
mean that too in a sense
oh you know what i mean but if the other
can't be spare me this now
i i wouldn't have come but but oh i did
i did try to keep away it was
intolerable
heartbreaking but what could he do what
could he say
he did not love her let me go
i'm not wanted let me take away what's
left of me
dear elsie you're very dear to me but
again she made the gesture
as of putting something violently aside
no not that
not anything less don't offer me
anything less
leave me a little pride let me get my
hat and coat let me take you to a doctor
he muttered but she refused she refused
even the support of his arm
she gave another unsteady laugh i'm
sorry i broke your stairs paul
you will go and see about the short
stories won't you
he groaned then if you won't see a
doctor will you go across the square and
let mrs barrett look at you
look there's barrett passing now the
long-nosed barrett was looking curiously
down the alley but as aleran was about
to call him he made off without a word
elsie seemed anxious for nothing so much
as to be clear of the place
and finally promised to go straight to a
doctor but insisted on going alone
goodbye she said and aleran watched her
until she was past the hatchet-like
tillett boards
as if he feared that even they might
fall upon her and maim her
that night oleron did not dine he had
far too much on his mind
he walked from room to room of his flat
as if he could have walked away from
elsie bengo's haunting cry that still
rang in his ears
i'm not wanted don't offer me anything
less
let me take away what's left of me oh if
he could only have persuaded himself
that he loved her
he walked until twilight fell then
without lighting candles
he stirred up the fire and flung himself
into a chair
poor poor elsie but even while his heart
ached for her
it was out of the question if only he
had known
if only he had used common observation
but those
walks those sisterly takings of the arm
what a fool he had been
well it was too late now it was she
not he who must now act act by keeping
away
he would help her all he could he
himself would not sit in her presence
if she came he would hurry her out again
as fast as he could
poor poor elsie his room grew dark
the fire burned dead and he continued to
sit
wincing from time to time as a fresh
tortured phrase rang again in his ears
then suddenly he knew not why he found
himself anxious for her
in a new sense uneasy about her personal
safety
a horrible fancy that even then she
might be looking over an embankment down
into dark water
that she might even now be glancing up
at the hook on the door
took him women had been known to do
those things
then there would be an inquest and he
himself would be called upon to identify
her
and would be asked how she had come by
an ill-healed wound on the hand and a
bad abrasion of the ankle
barrett would say that he had seen her
leaving his house
then he recognized that his thoughts
were morbid by an effort of will he put
them aside
and sat for a while listening to the
faint creakings and tickings and
wrappings within his paneling
if only he could have married her but he
couldn't
her face had risen before him again as
he had seen it on the stairs
drawn with pain and ugly and swollen
with tears
ugly yes positively blubbered
if tears were women's weapons as they
were said to be
such tears were weapons turned against
themselves
suicide again then all at once he found
himself attentively considering her two
accidents
extraordinary they had been both of them
he could not have left that old nail
standing in the wood why he had fetched
tools especially from the kitchen
and he was convinced that that step that
had broken beneath her weight had been
as sound as the others
it was inexplicable if these things
could happen
anything could happen there was not a
beam or a jam in the place that might
not fall without warning
not a plank that might not crash inwards
not a nail that might not become a
dagger
the whole place was full of life even
now as he sat there in the dark he heard
its crowds of noises as if the house had
been one great microphone
only half conscious that he did so he
had been sitting for some time
identifying these noises attributing to
each crack or creak or knock its
material cause
but there was one noise which again not
fully conscious of the omission
he had not sought to account for it had
last come
some minutes ago it came again now
a sort of soft sweeping rustle that
seemed to hold an almost inaudibly
minute crackling
for half a minute or so it had aleran's
attention
then his heavy thoughts were of elsie
bengo again he was nearer to loving her
in that moment than he ever had been
he thought how to some men their loved
ones were but the dearer for those poor
mortal blemishes that tell us we are but
sojourners on earth
with a common fate not far distant that
makes it hardly worthwhile to do
anything but love
for the time remaining strangling sobs
blearing tears bodies buffeted by
sickness
hearts and minds callous and hard with
the rubs of the world
how little love there would be were
these things a barrier to love
in that sense he did love elsie bengo
but her happiness had never moved in him
her sorrow almost awoke suddenly his
meditation went
his ear had once more become conscious
of that soft and repeated noise
the long sweep with the almost inaudible
crackle in it
again and again it came with a curious
insistence and urgency
it quickened a little as he became
increasingly attentive
it seemed to alerron that it grew louder
all at once he started bolt upright in
his chair
tense and listening the silky russell
came again
he was trying to attach it to something
the next moment he had leaped to his
feet unnerved and terrified
his chair hung poised for a moment and
then went over
setting the fire irons clattering as it
fell
there was only one noise in the world
like that which had caused him to spring
thus to his feet
the next time it came aleron felt behind
him at the empty air with his hand
and backed slowly until he found himself
against the wall
god in heaven the ejaculation broke from
aleran's lips
the sound had ceased the next moment he
had given a high cry
what is it what's there who's there
a sound of scuttling caused his knees to
bend under him for a moment
but that he knew was a mouse that was
not something that his stomach turned
sick and his mind reeled to entertain
that other sound the like of which was
not in the world
had now entirely ceased and again he
called
he called and continued to call and then
another terror
a terror of the sound of his own voice
seized him
he did not dare to call again his
shaking hand went to his pocket for a
match
but found none he thought there might be
matches on the mantelpiece
he worked his way to the mantelpiece
round a little recess without for a
moment leaving the wall
then his hand encountered the
mantelpiece and groped along it
a box of matches fell to the hearth he
could just see them in the fire light
but his hand could not pick them up
until he had cornered them inside the
fender
then he rose and struck a light the room
was as usual
he struck a second match a candle stood
on the table
he lighted it and the flame sank for a
moment and then burned up clear
again he looked round there was nothing
there was nothing but there had been
something and might still be something
formerly aleran had smiled at the
fantastic thought
that by emerging an interplay of
identities between himself and his
beautiful room
he might be preparing a ghost for the
future it had not occurred to him that
there might have been a similar merging
and coalescence
in the past yet with this staggering
impossibility
he was now face to face something did
persist
in the house it had a tenant other than
himself
and that tenant whatsoever or whosoever
had a paul dalaran's soul by producing
the sound of a woman brushing her hair
without quite knowing how he came to be
there aleran found himself striding over
the loose board he had temporarily
placed on the step broken by miss bengo
he was hatless and descending the stairs
not until later did their return to him
a hazy memory that he had left the
candle burning on the table
had opened the door no wider than was
necessary to allow the passage of his
body
and had sidled out closing the door
softly behind him
at the foot of the stairs another shock
awaited him something dashed with a
flurry up from the disused cellars and
disappeared out of the door
it was only a cat but aleran gave a
childish sob
he passed out of the gate and stood for
a moment under the tillette boards
plucking foolishly at his lip and
looking up at the glimmer of light
behind one of his red blinds
then still looking over his shoulder he
moved stumblingly up the square
there was a small public house round the
corner aleran had never entered it
but he entered it now and put down a
shilling that missed the counter by
inches
brandy he said and then stooped to look
for the shilling
he had the little sawdusted bar to
himself what company there was
carters and laborers and the small
tradesmen of the neighborhood
was gathered in the farther compartment
beyond the space where the white-haired
landlady moved
among her taps and bottles aleran sat
down on a hardwood settee with a
perforated seat
drank half his brandy and then thinking
he might as well drink it as spill it
finished it then he fell to wondering
which of the men
whose voices he heard across the public
house would undertake the removal of his
effects on the morrow
in the meantime he ordered more brandy
for he did not intend to go back to that
room where he had left the candle
burning
oh no he couldn't have faced even the
entry in the staircase with a broken
step
certainly not that pith white
fascinating room
he would go back for the present to his
old arrangement of work room and
separate sleeping quarters
he would go to his old landlady at once
presently when he had finished his
brandy
and see if she could put him up for the
night his glass was empty now
he rose had it refilled and sat down
again
and if anybody asked his reason for
removing again
oh he had reason enough reason enough
nails that put themselves back into wood
again and gashed people's hands
steps that broke when you trod on them
and women who came into a man's place
and brushed their hair in the dark were
reasons enough
he was queerless and injured about it
all he had taken the place for himself
not for invisible women to brush their
hair in that lawyer fellow in lincoln's
inn should be told so too
before many hours were out it was
outrageous letting people in for
agreements like that
a cut glass partition divided the
compartment where aleron sat from the
space where the white-haired landlady
moved
but it stopped seven or eight inches
above the level of the counter
there was no partition at the farther
bar presently aleran raising his eyes
saw that faces were watching him through
the aperture
the faces disappeared when he looked at
them
he moved to a corner where he could not
be seen from the other bar
but this brought him into line with the
white-haired landlady
she knew him by sight had doubtless seen
him passing and re-passing
and presently she made a remark on the
weather
aleran did not know what he replied but
it sufficed to call forth the further
remark that the winter had been a bad
one for influenza
but that the spring weather seemed to be
coming at last
even this slight contact with the
commonplace steady dollar on a little
an idle nascent wonder whether the
landlady brushed her hair every night
and if so whether it gave out those
little electric cracklings
was shut down with a snap and aleran was
better
with his next glass of brandy he was all
for going back to his flat
not go back indeed he would go back
they should very soon see whether he was
to be turned out of his place like that
he began to wonder why he was doing the
rather unusual thing he was doing at
that moment
unusual for him sitting hatless drinking
brandy in a public house
suppose he were to tell the white-haired
landlady all about it
to tell her that a caller had scratched
her hand on a nail
had later had the bad luck to put her
foot through a rotten stare
and that he himself in an old house full
of squeaks and creaks and whispers
had heard a minute noise and had bolted
from it in fright
what would she think of him that he was
mad of course
the real truth of the matter was that he
hadn't been doing enough work to occupy
him
he had been dreaming his days away
filling his head with a lot of moonshine
about a new romaly
as if the old one was not good enough
and now he was surprised that the devil
should enter an empty head
yes he would go back he would take a
walk in the air first
he hadn't walked enough lately and then
he would take himself in hand
settle the hash of that 16th chapter of
romilly
fancy he had actually been fool enough
to think of destroying 15 chapters
and thenceforward he would remember that
he had obligations to his fellow men
and work to do in the world there was
the matter in a nutshell
he finished his brandy and went out
he had walked for some time before any
other bearing of the matter than that on
himself occurred to him
at first the fresh air had increased the
heady effect of the brandy he had drunk
but afterwards his mind grew clearer
than it had been since morning
and the clearer it grew the less final
that his boastful self-assurances become
and the firmer his conviction that when
all explanations had been made
there remained something that could not
be explained
his hysteria of an hour before had
passed he grew steadily calmer
but the disquieting conviction remained
a deep fear took possession of him
it was a fear for elsie
for something in his place was inimical
to her safety
of themselves her two accidents might
not have persuaded him of this
but she herself had said it i'm not
wanted here
and she had declared that there was
something wrong with the place
she had seen it before he had well and
good
one thing stood out clearly namely that
if this was so
she must be kept away for quite another
reason than that which had so confounded
and humiliated aleran
luckily she had expressed her intention
of staying away
she must be held to that intention he
must see to it
and he must see to it all the more that
he now saw his first impulse
never to set foot in the place again was
absurd
people did not do that kind of thing
with elsie made secure
he could not with any respect to himself
suffer himself to be turned out by a
shadow
nor even by a danger merely because it
was a danger
he had to live somewhere and he would
live there
he must return he mastered the faint
chill of fear that came with the
decision
and turned in his walk abruptly should
fear grow on him again he would perhaps
take one more glass of brandy but by the
time he reached the short street that
led to the square
he was too late for more brandy the
little public house was still lighted
but closed and one or two men were
standing talking on the curb
aleran noticed that a sudden silence
fell on them as he passed
and he noticed further that the
long-nosed barrett whom he passed a
little lower down
did not return his good night he turned
in at the broken gate
hesitated merely an instant in the alley
and then mounted his stairs again
only an inch of candle remained in the
sheffield stick and aleran did not laid
another one
deliberately he forced himself to take
it up and to make the tour of his five
rooms before retiring
it was as he returned from the kitchen
across his little hall
that he noticed that a letter lay on the
floor
he carried it into his sitting room and
glanced at the envelope before opening
it
it was unstamped and had been put into
the door by hand
its handwriting was clumsy and it ran
from beginning to end without comma or
period
aleran read the first line turned to the
signature
and then finished the letter it was from
the man barrett
and it informed dalaran that he barrett
would be obliged if mr aleran would make
other arrangements for the preparing of
his breakfast
and the cleaning out of his place the
sting lay in the tail
that is to say the postscript this
consisted of a text of scripture
it embodied an illusion that could only
be to elsie bengo
a seldom seen frown had cut deeply into
aleron's brow
so that was it very well they would see
about that on the morrow
for the rest this seemed merely another
reason why elsie should keep away
then his suppressed rage broke out the
foul-minded lot
the devil himself could not have given a
lear at anything that it ever passed
between paul aleran and elsie bengo
yet this nosing rascal must be prying
and talking
aleron crumpled the paper up held it in
the candle flame
and then ground the ashes under his heel
one useful purpose however the letter
had served
it had created an aleran a wrathful
blaze that effectually banished pale
shadows
nevertheless one other puzzling
circumstance was to close the day
as he undressed he chanced to glance at
his bed
the coverlets bore an impress as if
somebody had lain on them
aleran could not remember that he
himself had laying down during the day
offhand he would have said that
certainly he had not
but after all he could not be positive
his indignation for elsie
acting possibly with the residue of the
brandy in him excluded all other
considerations
and he put out his candle lay down and
passed immediately into a deep and
dreamless sleep
which in the absence of mrs barrett's
morning call
lasted almost once round the clock
to the man who pays heed to that voice
within him which warns him that twilight
and danger are settling over his soul
terror is apt to appear an absolute
thing against which his heart
must be safeguarded in a twink unless
there is to take place in alteration in
the whole range and scale of his nature
mercifully he has never far to look for
safeguards
of the immediate and small and common
and momentary things of life
of usages and observances and modes and
conventions
he builds up fortifications against the
powers of darkness
he is even content that not terror only
but joy also
should for working purposes be placed in
the category of the absolute things
and the last treason he will commit will
be that breaking down of terms and
limits that strikes
not at one man but at the welfare of the
souls of all
in his own person aleran began to commit
this treason
he began to commit it by admitting the
inexplicable and horrible
to an increasing familiarity he did it
insensibly
unconsciously by a neglect of the things
that he now regarded it as an
impertinence in elsie bengo to have
prescribed
two months before the words a haunted
house
applied to his lovely bemusing dwelling
would have chilled his marrow
now his scale of sensation becoming
depressed he could ask
haunted by what and remain unconscious
that horror
when it can be proved to be relative by
so much loses its proper quality
he was setting aside the landmarks mists
and confusion had begun to unwrap him
and he was conscious of nothing so much
as of a voracious inquisitiveness
he wanted to know he was resolved to
know
nothing but the knowledge would satisfy
him and craftily he cast about for means
whereby he might attain it
he might have spared his craft the
matter was the easiest imaginable
as in time passed he had known in his
writing moments when his thoughts had
seemed to rise of themselves and to
embody themselves in words not to be
altered afterwards
so now the questions he put himself
seemed to be answered
even in the moment of their asking there
was exhilaration in the swift easy
processes
he had known no such joy in his own
power since the days when his writing
had been a daily
freshness and a delight to him it was
almost as if the course he must pursue
was being dictated to him
and the first thing he must do of course
was to define the problem
he defined it in terms of mathematics
granted that he had not the place to
himself
granted that the old house had
inexpressibly caught and engaged his
spirit
granted that by virtue of the common
denominator of the place
this unknown cotenant stood in some
relation to himself
what next clearly the nature of the
other numerator must be ascertained
and how ordinarily this would not have
seemed simple
but to alerron it was now pollutedly
clear the key
of course lay in his half-written novel
or rather in both romillies the old and
the proposed new one
a little while before aleran would have
thought himself mad to have embraced
such an opinion
now he accepted the dizzying hypothesis
without a quiver
he began to examine the first and second
romales
from the moment of his doing so the
thing advanced by leaps and bounds
swiftly he reviewed the history of the
romalee of the 15 chapters
he remembered clearly now that he had
found her insufficient on the very first
morning on which he had sat down to work
in his new place
other instances of his aversion leaped
up to confirm his obscure investigation
there had come the night when he had
hardly foreborn to throw the whole thing
into the fire
and the next morning he had begun the
planning of the new romaly
it had been on that morning that mrs
barrett overhearing him humming a brief
phrase that the dripping of a tap the
night before had suggested
had informed him that he was singing
some air he had never in his life heard
before
called the beckoning fair one the
beckoning fair one
with scarcely a pause and thought he
continued
the first romilly having been definitely
thrown over
the second had instantly fastened
herself upon him
clamoring for birth in his brain he even
fancied now looking back
that there had been something like
passion hate almost
in the supplanting and that more than
once a stray thought given to his
discarded creation had
it was astonishing how credible aleran
found the almost unthinkable idea
had offended the supplanter yet that a
malignancy almost homicidal
should be extended to his fiction's poor
mortal prototype
in spite of his inuring to a scale in
which the horrible was now a thing to be
fingered and turned this way in that
a good god broke from aleran
this intrusion of the first romilly's
prototype into his thought again
was a factor that for the moment brought
his inquiry into the nature of his
problem to a termination
the mere thought of elsie was fatal to
anything abstract
for another thing he could not yet think
of that letter of barrett's
nor of a little scene that had followed
it without a mounting of color and a
quick contraction of the brow
for wisely or not he had had that
argument out at once
striding across the square on the
following morning he had bearded barrett
on his own doorstep
coming back again a few minutes later he
had been strongly of opinion that he had
only made matters worse
the man had been vagueness itself he had
not been to be either challenged or brow
beaten into anything more definite than
a muttered ferrago
in which the words certain things mrs
barrett
respectable house if the cap fits
proceedings that shall be nameless
had been constantly repeated not that i
make any charge
he had concluded charge alerted cried
i have my ideas of things as i don't
doubt you have yours
ideas mine aleran had cried wrathfully
immediately dropping his voice as heads
had appeared at windows of the square
look you hear my man you have an
unwholesome mind which probably you
can't help
but a tongue which you can help and
shall if there is a breath of this
repeated
i'll not be talked to on my own doorstep
like this by anybody
barrett had blustered you shall and i'm
doing it
don't you forget there's a god above all
who has said
you're a low scandal monger and so forth
continuing badly what was already badly
begun
aleran had returned wrathfully to his
own house and thenceforward looking out
of his windows
had seen barrett's face at odd times
lifting blinds or peering around
curtains
as if he sought to put himself in
possession of heaven knew what evidence
in case it should be required of him the
unfortunate occurrence made certain
minor differences in aleran's domestic
arrangements
barrett's tongue he gathered had already
been busy
he was looked at askance by the dwellers
of the square
and he judged it better until he should
be able to obtain other help
to make his purchases of provisions a
little farther afield
rather than at the small shops of the
immediate neighborhood
for the rest housekeeping was no new
thing to him and he would resume his old
bachelor habits
besides he was deep in certain rather
abstruse investigations in which it was
better that he should not be disturbed
he was looking out of his window one
midday rather tired
not very well and glad that it was not
very likely he would have to stir
out of doors when he saw elsie bengo
crossing the square towards his house
the weather had broken it was a raw and
gusty day
and she had to force her way against the
wind that set her ample skirts bellying
about her opulent figure
and her veil spinning and streaming
behind her
aleran acted swiftly and instinctively
seizing his hat he sprang to the door
and descended the stairs at a run
a sort of panic had seized him she must
be prevented from setting foot in the
place
as he ran along the alley he was
conscious that his eyes went up to the
eaves as if something drew them
he did not know that a slate might not
accidentally fall
he met her at the gate and spoke with
curious volubleness
this is really too bad elsie just as i'm
urgently called away
i'm afraid it can't be helped though and
that you'll have to think me an
inhospitable beast
he poured it out just as it came into
his head
she asked if he was going to town yes
yes
to town he replied i've got to call on
on chambers
you know chambers don't you no i
remember you don't
a big man you once saw me with i ought
to have gone yesterday and
this he felt to be a brilliant effort
and he's going out of town this
afternoon to brighton
i had a letter from him this morning he
took her arm and led her up the square
she had to remind him that his way to
town lay in the other direction
of course how stupid of me he said with
a little loud laugh
i'm so used to going the other way with
you of course it's the other way to the
bus
will you come along with me i'm so
awfully sorry it's happened like this
they took the street to the bus terminus
this time
elsie bore no signs of having gone
through interior struggles
if she detected anything unusual in his
manner she made no comment
and he seeing her calm began to talk
less recklessly through silences
by the time they reached the bus
terminus nobody seeing the pallid-faced
man without an overcoat and the large
ample skirted girl
at his side would have supposed that one
of them was ready to sink on his knees
for thankfulness
that he had as he believed saved the
other from a wildly unthinkable danger
they mounted to the top of the bus
aleran protesting that he should not
miss his overcoat and that he found the
day if anything
rather oppressively hot they sat down on
a front seat
now that this meeting was forced upon
him he had something else to say that
would make demands upon his tact it had
been on his mind for some time
and was indeed peculiarly difficult to
put
he revolved it for some minutes and then
remembering the success of his story of
a sudden call to town
cut the knot of his difficulty with
another lie
i'm thinking of going away for a little
while elsie he said
she merely said oh somewhere for a
change
i need a change i think i shall go
tomorrow or the day after
yes tomorrow i think yes she replied
i don't quite know how long i shall be
he continued
i shall have to let you know when i'm
back yes
let me know she replied in an even tone
the tone was for her suspiciously even
he was a little uneasy you don't ask me
where i'm going
he said with a little cumbers effort to
rally her
she was looking straight before her past
the bus driver
i know she said he was startled
how you know you're not going anywhere
she replied he found not a word to say
it was a minute or so before she
continued and the same controlled voice
she had employed from the start
you're not going anywhere you weren't
going out this morning
you only came out because i appeared
don't behave as if we're strangers paul
a flush of pink had mounted to his
cheeks he noticed that the wind had
given her the pink of early rhubarb
still he found nothing to say of course
you ought to go away she continued i
don't know whether you look at yourself
often in the glass
but you're rather noticeable several
people have turned to look at you this
morning
so of course you ought to go away but
you won't
and i know why he shivered coughed a
little
and then broke silence then if you know
there's no use in continuing this
discussion he said
curtly not for me perhaps but there is
for you
she replied shall i tell you what i know
no he said in a voice slightly raised
no she asked her round eyes earnestly on
him
no again he was getting out of patience
with her
again he was conscious of the strain her
devotion
and fidelity and love plagued him she
was only humiliating both herself and
him
it would have been bad enough had he
ever by word or deed given her cause for
thus fastening herself
on him but there that was the worst of
that kind of life for a woman
women such as she business women in and
out of offices all the time
always whether they realized it or not
made comradeship a cover for something
else
they accepted the unconventional status
came and went freely as men did
were honestly taken by men at their own
valuation
and then it turned out to be the other
thing after all and they went and fell
in love
no wonder there was gossip in shops and
squares and public houses
in a sense the gossipers were in the
right of it
independent yet not efficient with some
of womanhood's graces
foregone and yet with all the woman's
hunger and need
half sophisticated yet not wise aleran
was tired of it all
and it was time he told her so i suppose
he said tremblingly looking down between
his knees
i suppose the real trouble is in the
life women who earn their own living are
obliged to lead
he could not tell in what sense she took
the lame generality
she merely replied i suppose so
it can't be helped he continued but you
do sacrifice a good deal
she agreed a good deal and then she
added after a moment
what for instance you may or may not be
gradually attaining a new status but
you're in a false position today
it was very likely she said she hadn't
thought of it much in that light
and he continued desperately you're
bound to suffer
your most innocent acts are
misunderstood motives you never dreamed
of
are attributed to you and in the end it
comes to
he hesitated a moment and then took the
plunge to the sidelong look in the lear
she took his meaning with perfect ease
she merely shivered a little as she
pronounced the name
barrett his silence told her the rest
anything further that was to be said
must come from her
it came as the bus stopped at a stage
and fresh passengers mounted the stairs
you'd better get down here and go back
paul she said
i understand perfectly perfectly it
isn't barrett
you'd be able to deal with barrett it's
merely convenient for you to say it's
barrett
i know what it is but you said i wasn't
to tell you that
very well but before you go let me tell
you why i came up this morning
in a dull tone he asked her why again
she looked straight before her as she
replied
i came to force your hand things
couldn't go on as they have been going
you know
and now that's all over all over
he repeated stupidly all over
i want you now to consider yourself as
far as i'm concerned
perfectly free i make only one
reservation
he hardly had the spirit to ask her what
that was
if i merely need you she said please
don't give that a thought
that's nothing i shan't come near for
that
but she dropped her voice if you're in
need of me
paul i shall know if you are and you
will be
then i shall come at no matter what cost
you understand that
he could only groan so that's understood
she concluded and i think that's all now
go back
i should advise you to walk back for
your shivering
goodbye she gave him a cold hand
and he descended he turned on the edge
of the curb as the bus started again
for the first time in all the years he
had known her she parted from him with
no smile
and no wave of her long arm
he stood on the curb plunged in misery
looking after her as long as she
remained in sight
but almost instantly with her
disappearance he felt the heaviness lift
a little from his spirit
she had given him his liberty true there
was a sense in which he had never parted
with it
but now was no time for splitting hairs
he was free to act
and all was clear ahead swiftly the
sense of lightness grew on him
it became a positive rejoicing in his
liberty and before he was halfway home
he had decided what must be done next
the vicar of the parish in which his
dwelling was situated
lived within 10 minutes of the square to
his house aleran turned his steps it was
necessary that he should have all the
information he could get about this old
house with the insurance marks and the
sloping tillett boards
and the vicar was the person most likely
to be able to furnish it
this last preliminary out of the way and
aha
aleran chuckled things might be expected
to happen
but he gained less information than he
had hoped for
the house the vicar said was old but
there needed no vicar to tell all around
that
it was reputed aleran pricked up his
ears to be haunted
but there were few old houses about
which some such rumor did not circulate
amongst the ignorant
and the deplorable lack of faith of the
modern world the vicar thought
did not tend to dissipate these
superstitions
for the rest his manner was the soothing
manner of one who prefers not to make
statements without knowing how they will
be taken by his hearer
aleran smiled as he perceived this
you may leave my nerves out of the
question he said
how long has the place been empty a
dozen years i should say
the vicar replied and the last tenant
did you know him or her aleran was
conscious of a tingling of his nerves as
he offered the vicar the alternative of
sex
him said the vicar a man if i remember
rightly his name was madly
an artist he was a great recluse seldom
went out of the place
and the vicar hesitated and then broke
into a little gush of candor
and since you appear to have come for
this information and since it is better
that the truth should be told then that
garbled version should get about
i don't mind saying that this man madly
died there under somewhat unusual
circumstances
it was ascertained at the postmortem
that there was not a particle of food in
his stomach
although he was found to be not without
money and his frame was simply worn out
suicide was spoken of but you'll agree
with me that deliberate starvation is
to say the least an uncommon form of
suicide
an open verdict was returned ah
said aleran does there happen to be any
comprehensive history of this parish
no partial ones only i myself am not
guiltless of having made a number of
notes on its purely ecclesiastical
history its registers and so forth
which i shall be happy to show you if
you would care to see them
but it is a large parish i have only one
curate and my leisure as you will
readily understand
the extent of the parish and the
scantiness of the vicar's leisure
occupied the remainder of the interview
and all around thanked the vicar
took his leave and walked slowly home
he walked slowly for a reason twice
turning away from the house within a
stone's throw of the gate
and taking another turn of 20 minutes or
so
he had a very ticklish piece of work now
before him
it required the greatest mental
concentration
it was nothing less than to bring his
mind if he might
into such a state of unpreoccupation and
receptivity
that he could see the place as he had
seen it on that morning
when his removal accomplished he had sat
down to begin the 16th chapter of the
first romilly
four could he recapture that first
impression he now hoped for far more
from it
formerly he had carried no end of mental
lumber
before the influence of the place had
been able to find him out at all
it had had the inertia of those dreary
chapters to overcome
no results had shown the process had
been one of slow saturation
charging filling up to a brim but now he
was light
unburdened rid at last both of that
romilly and of her prototype
now for the new unknown coy jealous
bewitching beckoning fair
at half past two of the afternoon he put
his key into the yale lock
entered and closed the door behind him
his fantastic attempt was instantly and
astonishingly successful
he could have shouted with triumph as he
entered the room
it was as if he had escaped into it once
more
as in the days when his writing had had
a daily freshness and wonder and promise
for him
he was conscious of that new ease and
mastery and exhilaration and release
the air of the place seemed to hold more
oxygen as if his own specific gravity
had changed
his very tread seemed less ponderable
the flowers and the bowls the fair
proportions of the meadow sweet colored
panels and moldings
the polished floor and the lofty and
faintly starred ceiling
fairly laughed their welcome aleran
actually laughed back
and spoke aloud oh you're pretty pretty
he flattered it then he lay down on his
couch
he spent that afternoon as a
convalescent who expected a dear visitor
might have spent it
in a delicious vacancy smiling now and
then as if in his sleep
and ever lifting drowsy and contented
eyes to his alluring surroundings
he lay thus until darkness came and with
darkness the nocturnal noises of the old
house
but if he waited for any specific
happening he waited in vain
he waited similarly in vain on the
morrow maintaining
though with less ease that sensitized
plate-like condition of his mind
nothing occurred to give it an
impression whatever it was which he so
patiently wooed
it seemed to be both shy and exacting
then on the third day he thought he
understood
a look of gentle drollery and cunning
came into his eyes
and he chuckled a hoe well if the wind
sits in that quarter
we must see what else there is to be
done what is there now
no i won't send for elsie we don't need
a wheel to break the butterfly on
we won't go to those lengths my
butterfly
he was standing musing thumbing his lean
jaw looking a slant
suddenly he crossed to his hall took
down his hat and went out
my lady is coquettish is she well we'll
see what a little neglect will do
he chuckled as he went down the stairs
he sought a railway station got into a
train
and spent the rest of the day in the
country oh yes
aleran thought he was the man to deal
with fair ones who beckoned and
invited and then took refuge in shyness
and hanging back
he did not return until after eleven
that night
now my fair beckoner he murmured as he
walked along the alley
and felt in his pocket for his keys
inside his flat he was perfectly
composed perfectly deliberate
exceedingly careful not to give himself
away
as if to intimate that he intended to
retire immediately
he lighted only a single candle and as
he set out with it on his nightly round
he affected to yawn
he went first into his kitchen there was
a full moon
and a lozenge of moonlight almost
peacock blue by contrast with his candle
flame
lay on the floor the window was
uncurtained and he could see the
reflection of the candle
and faintly that of his own face as he
moved about
the door of the powder closet stood a
little ajar and he closed it before
sitting down to remove his boots on the
chair with the cushion made of the
folded heartbag
from the kitchen he passed to the
bathroom there another slant a blue
moonlight cut the windowsill
and lay across the pipes on the wall he
visited his seldom-used study
and stood for a moment gazing at the
silvered roofs across the square
then walking straight through his
sitting room his stocking feet making no
noise
he entered his bedroom and put the
candle on the chest of drawers
his face all this time wore no
expression save that of tiredness he had
never been wildier
nor more alert his small bedroom
fireplace was opposite the chest of
drawers on which the mirror stood
and his bed in the window occupied the
remaining sides of the room
aleran drew down his blind took off his
coat
and then stooped to get his slippers
from under the bed
he could have given no reason for the
conviction but that the manifestation
that for two days had been withheld was
close at hand he never for an instant
doubted
nor though he could not form the
faintest guess of the shape it might
take
did he experience fear startling or
surprising it might be
he was prepared for that but that was
all
his scale of sensation had become
depressed
his hand moved this way and that under
the bed in search of his slippers
but for all his caution and method and
preparedness
his heart all at once gave a leap and a
pause that was almost horrid
his hand had found the slippers but he
was still on his knees
say for this circumstance he would have
fallen
the bed was a low one the groping for
the slippers accounted for the turn of
his head to one side
and he was careful to keep the attitude
until he had partly recovered his
self-possession
when presently he rose there was a drop
of blood on his lower lip where he had
caught at it with his teeth
and his watch had jerked out of the
pocket of his waistcoat and was dangling
at the end of its short leather guard
then before the watch had ceased its
little oscillation he was himself again
in the middle of his mantlepiece there
stood a picture a portrait of his
grandmother
he placed himself before this picture so
that he could see in the glass of it the
steady flame of the candle that burned
behind him on the chest of drawers
he could see also in the picture glass
the little glancings of light from the
bevels and facets of the objects about
the mirror and candle
but he could see more these twinklings
and reflections and re-reflections did
not change their position
but there was one gleam that had motion
it was fainter than the rest and it
moved up and down
through the air it was the reflection of
the candle on aleran's black vulcanite
comb
and each of its downward movements was
accompanied by a silky and crackling
rustle
aleran watching what went on in the
glass of his grandmother's portrait
continued to play his part he felt for
his dangling watch and began slowly to
wind it up
then for a moment ceasing to watch he
began to empty his trousers pockets and
to place
methodically in a little row on the
mantelpiece the pennies and half pennies
he took from
them the sweeping minutely electric
noise filled the whole bedroom
and at aleron altered his point of
observation he could have brought the
dim gleam of the moving comb
so into position that it would almost
have outlined his grandmother's head
any other head of which it might have
been following the outline was invisible
aleran finished the emptying of his
pockets then
under cover of another simulated yawn
not so much
summoning his resolution as overmastered
by an exorbitant curiosity
he swung suddenly round that which was
being combed was still not to be seen
but the comb did not stop it had altered
its angle a little
and it moved a little to the left it was
passing in fairly regular sweeps
from a point rather more than five feet
from the ground
in a direction roughly vertical to
another point a few inches below the
level of the chest of drawers
aleran continued to act to admiration he
walked to his little wash stand in the
corner
poured out water and began to wash his
hands
he removed his waistcoat and continued
his preparations for bed
the combing did not cease and he stood
for a moment and thought
again his eyes twinkled the next was
very cunning
hmm i think i'll read for a quarter of
an hour he said aloud
he passed out of the room he was away a
couple of minutes
when he returned again the room was
suddenly quiet
he glanced at the chest of drawers the
comb lay still
between the collar he had removed and a
pair of gloves
without hesitation aleran put out his
hand and picked it up
it was an ordinary 18-penny comb taken
from a card in a chemist shop
of a substance of a definite specific
gravity and no more capable of rebellion
against the laws by which it existed
that are the worlds that keep their
orbits through the void
aleran put it down again then he glanced
at the bundle of papers he held in his
hand
what he had gone to fetch had been the
15 chapters of the original romaly
he muttered as he threw the manuscript
into a chair as i thought
she's just blindly ragingly murderously
jealous
on the night after that and on the
following night and for many nights and
days
so many that he began to be uncertain
about the count of them
aleran courting cajoling neglecting
threatening beseeching eaten out with
unappeased curiosity
and regardless that his life was
becoming one consuming passion and
desire
continued his search for the unknown
co-numerator of his abode
as time went on it came to pass that few
except the postman
mounted all around stairs and since men
who do not write letters receive few
even the postman's tread became so
infrequent that it was not heard more
than once or twice a week
there came a letter from allaron's
publishers asking when they might expect
to receive the manuscript of his new
book
he delayed for some days to answer it
and finally forgot it
a second letter came which he also
failed to answer
he received no third the weather grew
bright and warm
the privet bushes among the chopper-like
notice boards flowered
and in the streets where alaran did his
shopping the baskets of flower women
lined the curbs
aleran purchased flowers daily his room
clamored for flowers
fresh and continually renewed and aleran
did not stint its demands
nevertheless the necessity for going out
to buy them began to irk him more and
more
and it was with a greater and ever
greater sense of relief that he returned
home again
he began to be conscious that again his
scale of sensation had suffered a subtle
change
a change that was not restoration to its
former capacity
but an extension and enlarging that once
more included terror
it admitted it in an entirely new form
lux orco tenebre jovi the name of this
terror was agoraphobia
aleran had begun to dread air in space
and the horror that might pounce upon
the unguarded back
presently he so contrived it that his
food and flowers were delivered daily at
his door
he rubbed his hands when he had hit upon
this expedient
that was better now he could please
himself whether he went out or not
quickly he was confirmed in his choice
it became his pleasure to remain immured
but he was not happy or if he was his
happiness took an extraordinary turn
he fretted discontentedly could
sometimes have wept for mere weakness
and misery
and yet he was dimly conscious that he
would not have exchanged his sadness
for all the noisy mirth of the world
outside
and speaking of noise noise much noise
now caused him the acutest discomfort
it was hardly more to be endured than
that newborn fear that kept him
on the increasingly rare occasions when
he did go out
sidling close to walls and feeling
friendly railings with his hand
he moved from room to room softly and in
slippers
and sometimes stood for many seconds
closing a door so gently
that not a sound broke the stillness
that was in itself a delight
sunday now became an intolerable day to
him for since the coming of the fine
weather
there had begun to assemble in the
square under his windows each sunday
morning
certain members of the sect to which the
long-nosed barrett adhered
these came with a great drum and large
brass bellied instruments
men and women uplifted anguished voices
struggling with their god
and barrett himself with upraised face
and closed eyes and working brows
prayed that the sound of his voice might
penetrate the ears of all unbelievers
as it certainly did alerans one day
in the middle of one of these rhapsodies
aleran sprang to his blind and pulled it
down
and heard as he did so his own name made
the subject of a fresh torrent of
outpouring
and sometimes but not as expecting a
reply
alerron stood still and called softly
once or twice he called romilly and then
waited
but more often his whispering did not
take the shape of a name
there was one spot in particular of his
abode that he began to haunt with
increasing persistency this was just
within the opening of his bedroom door
he had discovered one day that by
opening every door in his place
always accepting the outer one which he
only opened unwillingly
and by placing himself on this
particular spot he could actually see
to a greater or lesser extent into each
of his five rooms without changing his
position
he could see the whole of his sitting
room all of his bedroom
except the part hidden by the open door
and glimpses of his kitchen
bathroom and of his rarely used study he
was often in this place
breathless and with his finger on his
lip one day as he stood there
he suddenly found himself wondering
whether this madly of whom the vicar had
spoken
had ever discovered the strategic
importance of the bedroom entry
light moreover now caused him greater
disquietude than in darkness
direct sunlight of which as the sun
passed daily round the house
each of his rooms had now its share was
like a flame in his brain
and even diffused light was a dull and
numbing ache
he began at successive hours of the day
one after another
to lower his crimson blinds he made
short and daring excursions in order to
do this
but he was ever careful to leave his
retreat open in case he should have
sudden need of it
presently this lowering of the blinds
had become a daily methodical exercise
in his rooms when he had been his round
had the blood-red half-light of a
photographer's dark room
one day as he drew down the blind of his
little study and backed in good order
out of the room again
he broke into a soft laugh that bilks mr
barrett he said
and the baffling of barrett continued to
afford him mirth for an hour
but on another day soon after he had a
fright that left him trembling
also for an hour he had seized the cord
to darken the window over the seat in
which he had found the heartbag
and was standing with his back well
protected in the embrasure
when he thought he saw the tail of a
black and white czech skirt disappear
around the corner of the house
he could not be sure had he run to the
window of the other
wall which was blinded the skirt must
have been already passed
but he was almost sure that it was elsie
he listened in an agony of suspense for
her tread on the stairs
but no tread came and after three or
four minutes he drew a long breath of
relief
by jove but that would have compromised
me horribly he muttered
and he continued to mutter from time to
time horribly compromising
no woman would stand that not any kind
of woman
o compromising in the extreme yet he was
not happy
he could not have assigned the cause of
the fits of quiet weeping which took him
sometimes
they came and went like the fitful
illumination of the clouds that traveled
over the square
and perhaps after all if he was not
happy he was not
unhappy before he could be unhappy
something must have been withdrawn
and nothing had yet been withdrawn from
him for nothing had been granted
he was waiting for that granting in that
flower-laden frightfully enticing
apartment of his
with the pith white walls tinged and
subdued by the crimson blinds to a
bloodlike gloom
he paid no heed to it that his stock of
money was running perilously low
nor that he had ceased to work ceased to
work
he had not ceased to work they knew very
little about it who supposed that aleran
had ceased to work
he was in truth only now beginning to
work he was preparing such a work
such a work such a mistress was a making
in the gestation of his art
let him beget this period of probation
and poignant waiting over
and men should see how should men know
her
this fair one of allurons until aleron
himself knew her
lovely radiant creations are not thrown
off like howdy ado's
the men to whom it is committed to
father them must weep wretched tears as
aleran did
must swell with vain presumptuous hopes
as aleron did
must pursue as aleron pursued the
capricious
fair mocking slippery eager spirit
that ever eluding ever sees to it that
the chase does not slacken
let aleron but hunt this huntress a
little longer
he would have her sparkling and panting
in his arms yet
oh no they were very far from the truth
who supposed that aleran had ceased to
work
and if all else was falling away from
aleran gladly he was letting it go
so do we all when our fair ones beckon
quite at the beginning we wink and
promise
ourselves that we will put her ladyship
through her paces
neglect her for a day turn her own
jealous wiles against her flout and
ignore her when she comes wheedling
perhaps there lurks within us all the
time a heartless sprite who is never
fooled
but in the end all falls away she
beckons
beckons and all goes and so aleran kept
his strategic post within the frame of
his bedroom door
and watched and waited and smiled with
his finger on his lips
it was his dutious service his worship
his truth plating
all that he had ever known of love and
when he found himself
as he now and then did hating the dead
man madly
and wishing that he had never lived he
felt that that too
was an acceptable service but as he thus
prepared himself as it were
for a marriage and moped and chaffed
more and more that the bride made no
sign he made a discovery that he ought
to have made weeks before
it was through a thought of the dead
madly that he made it
since that night when he had thought in
his greenness that a little steadied
neglect would bring the lovely beckoner
to her knees
and had made use of her own jealousy to
banish her he had not set eyes on those
15 discarded chapters of romilly
he had thrown them back into the window
seat forgotten their very existence
but his own jealousy of madly put him in
mind of hers of her jilted rival of
flesh and blood
and he remembered them full that he had
been
had he then expected his desire to
manifest herself while there still
existed the evidence of his divided
allegiance
what and she with a passion so fierce
and centered that it had not hesitated
at the destruction
twice attempted of her rival full that
he had been
but if that was all the pledge and
sacrifice she required
she would have it ah yes and quickly he
took the manuscript from the window seat
and brought it to the fire he kept his
fire
always burning now the warmth brought
out the last vestige of odor of the
flowers with which his room was banked
he did not know what time it was long
since he had allowed his clock to run
down
it had seemed a foolish measure of time
and regard to the stupendous things that
were happening to aleran
but he knew it was late he took the
romilly manuscript and knelt before the
fire
but he had not finished removing the
fastening that held the sheets together
before he suddenly gave a start
turned his head over his shoulder and
listened intently
the sound he had heard had not been loud
it had been indeed no more than a tap
twice or thrice repeated but it had
filled all around with alarm
his face grew dark as it came again
he heard a voice outside on his landing
paul
paul it was elsie's voice
paul i know you're in i want to see you
he cursed her under his breath but kept
perfectly still
he did not intend to admit her paul
you're in trouble i believe you're in
danger at least come to the door
aleran smothered a low laugh it somehow
amused him that she
in such danger herself should talk to
him of his danger
well if she was serve her right she knew
or said she knew all about it paul
paul paul paul he mimicked her under his
breath
oh paul it's horrible horrible was it
thought aleran then let her get away
i only want to help you paul i didn't
promise not to come if you needed me
he was impervious to the pitiful sob
that interrupted the low cry
the devil take the woman should he shout
to her to go away and not come back
no let her call and knock and sob she
had a gift for sobbing
she mustn't think her sobs would move
him they irritated him
so that he set his teeth and shook his
fist at her but that was all
let her sob paul paul
with his teeth hard set he dropped the
first page of romilly into the fire
then he began to drop the rest in sheet
by sheet
for many minutes the calling behind his
door continued
then suddenly it ceased he heard the
sound of feet slowly descending the
stairs
he listened for the noise of a fall or a
cry or the crash of a piece of the
handrail of the upper landing
but none of these things came she was
spared
apparently her rival suffered her to
crawl abject and beaten away
aleran heard the passing of her steps
under his window then she was gone
he dropped the last page into the fire
and then with a low laugh
rose he looked fondly round his room
lucky to get away like that he remarked
she wouldn't have got away if i'd given
her as much as a word or a look
what devils these women are but no i
ought to say that
one of them showed forbearance who
showed forbearance
and what was forborn ah aleran knew
contempt no doubt had been at the bottom
of it but that didn't matter
the pestering creature had been allowed
to go unharmed
yes she was lucky alerron hoped she knew
it
and now now for his reward
aleran crossed the room all his doors
were open
his eyes shone as he placed himself
within that of his bedroom
full that he had been not to think of
destroying the manuscript sooner
how in a house full of shadows should he
know his own shadow
how in a house full of noises
distinguished the summons he felt to be
at hand
ah trust him he would know the place was
full of a jugglery of dim
lights the blind at his elbow that
allowed the light of a street lamp to
struggle vaguely through
the glimpse of greeny blue moonlight
seen through the distant kitchen door
the sulky glow of the fire under the
black ashes of the burnt manuscript
the glimmering of the tulips and the
moon daisies and narcissi
and the bowls and jugs and jars these
did not so trick and bewilder his eyes
that he would not know his own
it was he not she who had been delaying
the shadowy bridle
he hung his head for a moment in mute
acknowledgement then he bent his eyes on
the deceiving puzzling gloom again
he would have called her name had he
known it but now he would not ask her to
share even a name with the other
his own face within the frame of the
door glimmered white as the narcissise
in the darkness
a shadow light as fleece seemed to take
shape in the kitchen
the time had been when aleron would have
said that a cloud had passed over the
unseen moon
the low illumination on the blind at his
elbow grew dimmer
the time had been when aleron would have
concluded that the lamplighter going as
rounds had turned low the flame of the
lamp
the fire settled letting down the black
and charred papers
a flower fell from a bowl and lay
indistinct upon the floor
all was still and then a stray draft
moved through the old house
passing before aleron's face suddenly
inclining his head
he withdrew a little from the doorjamb
the wandering draft caused the door to
move a little on its hinges
aleran trembled violently stood for a
moment longer
and then putting his hand out to the
knob softly drew the door
too sat down on the nearest chair and
waited
as a man might await the calling of his
name that should summon him to some
weighty high and privy audience
one knows not whether there can be human
compassion for anemia of the soul
when the pitch of life is dropped and
the spirit is so put over and reversed
that that only is horrible which before
was sweet and worldly and of the day
the human relation disappears the sane
soul turns appalled away
lest not merely itself but sanity should
suffer
we are not gods we cannot drive out
devils
we must see selfishly to it the devils
do not enter into ourselves
and this we must do even though love so
transfuse us that we may well deem our
nature to be half divine
we shall but speak of honor and duty in
vain
the letter dropped within the dark door
will lie unregarded or if regarded for a
brief instant between two unspeakable
lapses
left and forgotten again the telegram
will be undelivered
nor will the whistling messenger wisely
or guided than he knows to whistle
be conscious as he walks away of the
drawn blind that is pushed aside an inch
by a finger
and then fearfully replaced again no
let the miserable wrestle with his own
shadows let him
if indeed he be so mad clip and strain
and unfold and couch the succubus
but let him do so in a house into which
not an air of heaven penetrates
nor a bright finger of the sun pierces
the filthy twilight
the lost must remain lost humanity has
other business to attend to for the
handwriting of the two letters that
aleran
stealing noiselessly one june day into
his kitchen to rid his sitting room of
an armful of fetid and decaying flowers
had seen on the floor within his door
had had no more meaning for him
than if it had belonged to some dim and
far away dream
and at the beating of the telegraph boy
upon the door within a few feet of the
bed where he lay
he had gnashed his teeth and stopped his
ears he had pictured the lad
standing there just beyond his partition
among packets of provisions and bundles
of dead and dying flowers
for his outer landing was littered with
these aleran had feared to open his door
to take them in
after a week the aaron lads had reported
that there must be some mistake about
the order and had left no more
inside in the red twilight the old
flowers turned brown
and fell and decayed where they lay
gradually his power was draining away
the abomination fastened on aleron's
power
the steady sapping sometimes left him
for many hours of prostration
gazing vacantly up at his red-tinged
ceiling idly suffering such fancies as
came of themselves to have their way
with him
even the strongest of his memories had
no more than a precarious hold upon his
attention
sometimes a flitting half-memory of a
novel to be written
a novel that was important that he
should write tantalized him for a space
before vanishing again
and sometimes whole novels perfect
splendid established to endure
rose magically before him and sometimes
the memories were absurdly remote and
trivial
of garretts he had inhabited in lodgings
that had sheltered him
and so forth aleran had known a good
deal about such things in his time
but all that was now passed he had at
last found a place which he did not
intend to leave until they fetched him
out
a place that some might have thought a
little on the green sick side
that others might have considered to be
a little too redelete of long dead and
morbid things for a living man to be
mute up in
but ah so irresistible with such an
authority of its own
with such an associate of its own and a
place of such delights when once a man
had ceased to struggle against its
inexorable will
a novel somebody ought to write a novel
about a place like that
there must be lots to write about in a
place like that if one could but get to
the bottom of it
it had probably already been painted by
a man called madly who would live there
but aleran had not known this madly had
a strong feeling that he wouldn't have
liked him
would rather he had lived somewhere else
really couldn't stand the fellow
hated him madly in fact aha that was a
joke
he seriously doubted whether the man had
led the life he ought
aleran was in two minds sometimes
whether he wouldn't tell that long-nosed
guardian of the public morals across the
way about him
but probably he knew and had made his
praying hullabaloos for him
also that was his line
why aleron himself had had a dust-up
with him about something or other
some girl or other elsie bengo her name
was he remembered
aleron had moments of deep uneasiness
about this elsie bengo
or rather he was not so much uneasy
about her as restless about the things
she did
chief of these was the way in which she
persisted in thrusting herself into his
thoughts
and whenever he was quick enough he sent
her packing the moment she made her
appearance there
the truth was that she was not merely a
boar she had always been that
it had now come to the pitch when her
very presence and his fancy was inimical
to the full enjoyment of certain
experiences
she had no tact really ought to have
known that people are not at home to the
thoughts of everybody all the time
ought and mere politeness to have
allowed him certain seasons quite to
himself
and was monstrously ignorant of things
if she did not know
as she appeared not to know that there
were certain special hours when a man's
veins ran with fire
and daring and power in which well in
which he had a reasonable right to treat
folk as he had treated that prying
barrett
to shut them out completely but no up
she popped the thought of her and ruined
all
bright towering fabrics by the side of
which even those perfect magical novels
of which he dreamed were done and gray
vanished utterly at her intrusion it was
as if a fog should suddenly quench some
fair-beaming star
as if at the threshold of some golden
portal prepared for aleron
a pitch should suddenly gape as if a
bat-like shadow should turn the growing
dawn to murk in darkness again
therefore aleron strove to stifle even
the nascent thought of her
nevertheless there came an occasion on
which this woman bengo
absolutely refused to be suppressed
aleran could not have told exactly when
this happened
he only knew by the glimmer of the
street lamp on his blind that it was
sometime during the night
and that for some time she had not
presented herself
he had no warning none of her coming she
just came
was there strive as he would he could
not shake off the thought of her
nor the image of her face she haunted
him
but for her to come at that moment of
all moments
really it was past belief how she could
endure it aleran could not conceive
actually to look on as it were at the
triumph of arrival
good god it was monstrous tact reticence
he had never credited her with an
overwhelming amount of either
but he had never attributed mir oh there
was no word for it
monstrous monstrous did she intend
thence forward
good god to look on aleran felt the
blood rush up to the roots of his hair
with anger against her
damnation take her he choked but the
next moment his heat and resentment had
changed to a cold sweat of cowering fear
panic-stricken he strove to comprehend
what he had done
for though he knew not what he knew he
had done something
something fatal irreparable blasting
anger he had felt but not this blaze of
ire that suddenly flooded the twilight
of his consciousness with a white
infernal light
that appalling flash was not his not his
that open rift of bright and searing
hell not his
not his his had been the hand of a child
preparing a puny blow
but what was this other horrific hand
that was drawn back to strike in the
same place
had he set that in motion had he
provided the spark that had touched off
the whole accumulated power of that
formidable and relentless place
he did not know he only knew that that
poor igniting particle in himself was
blown out that oh
impossible a clinging kiss how else to
express it
had changed on his very lips to a
gnashing and a removal
and that for very pity of the awful odds
he must cry out to her
against whom he had lately raged to
guard herself guard herself
look out he shrieked aloud
the revulsion was instant as if a cold
slow billow had broken over him
he came too to find that he was lying in
his bed that the mist and horror that
had for so long and wrapped him had
departed
that he was paul aleran that he was sick
naked
helpless and unutterably abandoned and
alone
his faculties the weak answered at last
to his calls upon them
and he knew that it must have been a
hideous nightmare that had left him
sweating and shaking thus
yes he was himself paul aleran a tired
novelist
already passed the summit of his best
work and slipping downhill again
empty-handed from it all he had struck
short in his life's aim
he had tried too much had overestimated
his strength
and was a failure a failure
it all came to him in the single word
and wrapped in complete
it needed no sequential thought he was a
failure
he had missed and he had missed not one
happiness
but two he had missed the ease of this
world which men love
and he had missed also that other
shining prize for which men forego ease
the snatching and holding and triumphant
bearing up a loft of which is the only
justification of the mad adventurer who
hazards the enterprise
and there was no second attempt fate has
no moro
aleron's morrow must be to sit down to
profitless ill-done
unrequired work again and so on the
morrow after that
and the morrow after that and as many
morrows as there might be
he lay there weakly yet sanely
considering it
and since the whole attempt had failed
it was hardly worthwhile to consider
whether a little might not be saved from
the general wreck
no good would ever come of that
half-finished novel he had intended that
it should appear in the autumn
was under contract that it should appear
no matter
it was better to pay forfeit to his
publishers than to waste what days were
left
he was spent age was not far off
and paths of wisdom and sadness were the
properest for the remainder of the
journey if only he had chosen the wife
the child
the faithful friend at the fireside and
let them follow an ignis fattis that
list
in the meantime it began to puzzle him
exceedingly that he should be so weak
that his room should smell so
overpoweringly of decaying vegetable
matter
and that his hand chanting to stray to
his face in the darkness
should encounter a beard most
extraordinary
he began to mutter to himself have i
been ill
am i ill now and if so why have they
left me alone
extraordinary he thought he heard a
sound from the kitchen or bathroom
he rose a little on his pillow and
listened ah
he was not alone then it certainly would
have been extraordinary if they had left
him ill and alone
alone oh no he would be looked after
he wouldn't be left ill to shift for
himself
if everybody else had forsaken him he
could trust elsie bengo the dearest
chummy had for that
bless her faithful heart but suddenly a
short stifled spluttering cry rang
sharply out
paul it came from the kitchen
and in the same moment it flashed upon
aleran he knew not how
that 2 3 5 he knew not how many minutes
before
another sound unmarked at the time but
suddenly transfixing his attention now
had striven to reach his intelligence
this sound had been the slight touch
of metal on metal just such a sound as
aleron made when he put his key into the
lock
hello who's that he called sharply from
his bed
he had no answer he called again
hello who's there who is it
this time he was sure he heard noises
soft and heavy in the kitchen
this is a queer thing altogether he
muttered by jove i'm as weak as a kitten
too
hello there somebody called didn't they
elsie is that you
then he began to knock with his hand on
the wall at the side of his bed
elsie elsie you called didn't you
please come here whoever it is
there was a sound as of a closing door
and then silence
aleran began to get rather alarmed it
may be a nurse
he muttered elsie'd have to get me a
nurse of course
she'd sit with me as long as she could
spare the time brave lass
and she'd get a nurse for the rest but
it was awfully like her voice
elsie or whoever it is i can't make this
out at all
i must go and see what's the matter he
put one leg out of bed
feeling its feebleness he reached with
his hand for the additional support of
the wall
but before putting out the other leg he
stopped and considered
picking at his new found beard he was
suddenly wondering whether he dared go
into the kitchen
it was such a frightfully long way no
man knew what horror might not leap and
huddle on his shoulders if he went so
far
when a man has an overmastering impulse
to get back into bed he ought to take
heed of the warning and obey it
besides why should he go what was there
to go for
if it was that bengo creature again let
her look after herself
aleran was not going to have things
cramp themselves on his defenseless back
for the sake of such a spoilsport as she
if she was in let her let herself out
again and the sooner the better for her
aleran simply couldn't be bothered he
had his work to do
on the morrow he must set about the
writing of a novel with a heroine so
winsome
capricious adorable jealous wicked
beautiful
inflaming and altogether evil that men
should stand amazed
she was coming over him now he knew by
the alteration of the very air of the
room when she was near him
and that soft thrill of bliss that had
begun to stir in him never came
unless she was beckoning beckoning he
let go the wall and fell back into bed
again
as oh unthinkable the other half of that
kiss that a nash had interrupted was
placed
how else to convey it on his lips
robbing him of every breath
in the bright june sunlight a crowd
filled the square and looked up at the
windows of the old house with the
antique insurance marks and its walls of
red brick
and the agents notice boards hanging
like wooden choppers over the paling
two constables stood at the broken gate
of the narrow entrance alley
keeping folk back the women kept to the
outskirts of the throng
moving now and then as if to see the
drawn red blinds of the old house from a
new angle
and talking and whispers the children
were in the houses
behind closed doors a long-nosed man had
a little group about him and he was
telling some story over and over again
and another man little and fat and
wide-eyed sought to capture the
long-nosed man's audience with some
relation in which a key figured
and it was revealed to me that there had
been something that very afternoon
the long-nosed man was saying i was
standing there where constable saunders
is
or rather i was passing about my
business when they came out
there was no deceiving me oh no
deceiving me i saw her face
what was it like mr barrett a man asked
it was like hers whom our lord said to
woman doth any man accuse thee
white is paper and no mistake don't tell
me
and so i walked straight across to mrs
barrett and jay and i says
this must stop and stop at once we are
commanded to avoid evil i says
and it must come to an end now let him
get help elsewhere
and she says to me john she says it's
four and six pence a week
then was her words jane i says if it was
forty six thousand pounds it should stop
and from that day to this she hasn't set
foot inside that gate
there was a short silence then did mrs
barrett ever
see anything like somebody vaguely
inquired
barrett turned austerely on the speaker
what mrs barrett saw and mrs barrett
didn't see
shall not pass these lips even as it is
written keep thy tongue from speaking
evil
he said another man spoke he was pretty
near canned up in the wagon and horses
that night wernie jim
yes he hadn't half copped it not
standing treat much neither he was in
the bar
all on his own so he was we talked about
it
the fat scared-eyed man made another
attempt she got the key off of me
she had the number of it she come into
my shop of a tuesday evening
nobody heeded him shut your heads
a heavy laborer commented gruffly she
hasn't been found yet
here's the inspectors we shall know more
in a bit
two inspectors had come up and were
talking to the constables who guarded
the gate
the little fat man ran eagerly forward
saying that she had bought the key off
him
i remember the number because of its
being three ones and three threes
one one one three three three he
exclaimed excitedly
an inspector put him aside nobody's been
in
he asked one of the constables no sir
then you brockley come with us you smith
keep the gate there's a squad on its way
the two inspectors and the constable
passed down the alley and entered the
house
they mounted the wide carved staircase
this don't look as if he'd been out much
lately one of the inspectors muttered as
he kicked aside a litter of dead leaves
and paper that lay outside aleron's door
i don't think we need knock break a pain
brackley
the door had two glazed panels there was
a sound of shattered glass
and brackley put his hand through the
hole his elbow had made and drew back
the latch
choked one of the inspectors as they
entered let some light and air in quick
it stinks like a hearse
the assembly out in the square saw the
red blinds go up and the windows of the
old house flung open
that's better said one of the inspectors
putting his head out of the window
and drawing a deep breath that seems to
be the bedroom in there
will you go in sims while i go over the
rest
they had drawn up the bedroom blind also
and the waxy white emaciated man on the
bed had made a blinker of his hand
against the torturing flood of
brightness
nor could he believe that his hearing
was not playing tricks with him for
there were two policemen in his room
bending over him and asking where she
was he shook his head
this woman bengo goes by the name of
miss elsie bengo
do you hear where is she no good
brackley get him up
be careful with him i'll just shove my
head out the window i think
the other inspector had been through all
around study and had found nothing
and was now in the kitchen kicking aside
an ankle deep mass of vegetable refuse
that cumbered the floor
the kitchen window had no blind and was
overshadowed by the blank end of the
house across the alley
the kitchen appeared to be empty but the
inspector
kicking aside the dead flowers noticed
that a shuffling track that was not of
his making had been swept to a cupboard
in the corner
in the upper part of the door of the
cupboard was a square panel that looked
as if it slid on runners
the door itself was closed the inspector
advanced
put out his hand to the little knob and
slid the hatch along its groove
then he took an involuntary step back
again
framed in the aperture and falling
forward a little before it jammed again
in its frame
was something that resembled a large
lumpy pudding done up in a pudding bag
of faded brownie red freeze
ah said the inspector to close the hatch
again
he would have had to thrust that pudding
back with his hand and somehow he did
not quite like the idea of touching it
instead he turned the handle of the
cupboard itself
there was weight behind it so much
weight that after opening the door
three or four inches and peering inside
he had to put his shoulder to it in
order to close it again
in closing it he left sticking out a few
inches from the floor
a triangle of black and white checked
skirt
he went into the small hall all right he
called
they had got aleron into his clothes he
still used his hands as blinkers and his
brain was very confused
a number of things were happening that
he couldn't understand
he couldn't understand the extraordinary
mess of dead flowers there seemed to be
everywhere
he couldn't understand why there should
be police officers in his room
he couldn't understand why one of these
should be sent for a four-wheeler and a
stretcher
he couldn't understand what heavy
article they seemed to be moving about
in the kitchen
his kitchen what's the matter he
muttered sleepily
then he heard a murmur in the square and
the stopping of a four-wheeler outside
the police officer was at his elbow
again and all-around wondered why
when he whispered something to him he
should run off a string of words
something about used in evidence against
you they had lifted him to his feet and
were assisting him towards the door
no aleran couldn't understand it at all
they got him down the stairs and along
the alley aleran was aware of confused
angry shoutings
he gathered that a number of people
wanted to lynch somebody or other
then his attention became fixed on a
little fat frightened-eyed man who
appeared to be making a statement that
an officer was taking down in a notebook
i'd seen her with him they was often
together she came into my shop and said
it was for him
i thought it was all right 111 333 the
number was
the man was saying the people seemed to
be very angry
many police were keeping them back but
one of the inspectors had a voice that
oleron thought
quite kind and friendly he was telling
somebody to get somebody else into the
cab before something or other was
brought out
and aleran noticed that a four-wheeler
was drawn up at the gate
it appeared that it was himself who was
to be put into it and as they lifted him
up he saw that the inspector tried to
stand between him and something that
stood behind the cab
but was not quick enough to prevent
aleran seeing that this something was a
hooded stretcher
the angry voices sounded like a sea
something hard like a stone hit the back
of the cab
and the inspector followed aleran in and
stood with his back to the window
near the side where the people were the
door they had put aleran in
at remained open apparently till the
other inspector should come
and through the opening aleran had a
glimpse of the hatchet-like tillett
boards among the privet trees
one of them said that the key was at
number six
suddenly the raging of voices was hushed
along the entrance alley shuffling steps
were heard
and the other inspector appeared at the
cab door
right away he said to the driver he
entered
fastened the door after him and blocked
up the second window with his back
between the two inspectors aleran slept
peacefully
the cab moved down the square the other
vehicle went up the hill
the mortuary lay that way
you